[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the tony
michaels podcast and this is tony
michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
thanks brandon
[Music]
dark brandon
cancels student debt
to the american working class
and manga is mad about it
they're mad about it this morning f joe
biden
f joe biden
he's lowering gas prices and he's
canceling student debt he's doing all
sorts of things that he promised to do
a lot of people are upset because
they've already paid off their student
debt a lot of people are upset because
he didn't take it all off and he didn't
he didn't get rid of all debt
that's not what he said he was gonna do
he never said that's what he was gonna
do he always said that he was gonna do
just what he did today there's supposed
to be a press conference at 2 15 eastern
time you know that
our show is monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific for two
full hours
so we run till the two o'clock hour
here on the tony michaels podcast i
think we're going to stay live today
to carry the coverage
of joe biden's press conference i do
believe uh we'll also simulcast it to
the midas touch touch network you know
we simulcast this show to the midas
touch facebook page but i believe we're
going to go to a simulcast over to
the midas touch youtube page on the
midas touch network we're going to carry
that coverage over there so you can stay
right here
not just for the tony michaels podcast
but also
we will be covering the joe biden press
conference where he
will announce that he has kept his
promise
to the american people the american
working class
who work so hard
and for to pay not only their dues by
going to college but also paying that
debt in this country making tons of
money off that debt today
today he lays out his plan of exactly
how he's going to give the middle class
and the working people relief
i don't i don't know
if joe biden will go down
as a great president i don't know if
he'll go down as a good president
i think history will tell a great story
of joe biden's presidency so far
just because he's gotten so much done
with such slim majorities and he's done
so much that he promised he would do i
don't normally
praise joe biden on this show
and maybe today is the day that i do
that
because so so many times we have to be
focused on what the danger in our
country is
because there is still danger even
though joe biden is at the helm and he's
steering the ship
and he is doing the things that he
promised to the american people
and trying his best with the slimmest
majorities that he has in our congress
we have
in contrast grandpa poopy pants the
former guy the cheeto dust mobster
crying
crying about how they won't get back his
classified top secret documents he
thinks he owns them
now this is a stark contrast between
these two [ __ ]
joe biden and donald trump that's what
i'm talking about what a stark contrast
today that you will see
in the news
trump is crying about the crimes that he
committed against the american people
remember that folks these are crimes
against the american people it is
against our government
he is putting our national security our
men and women who serve our country at
risk
when he's doing these stupid [ __ ]
things
and no telling why he's whining and
crying that he can't have his top secret
documents back they're not yours
[ __ ] and i've said that time and
time and time and time again on this
show and i will continue to say it those
are our documents that is our office
that you held
even even held criminally it seems in
some sort
or fashion
but joe biden understands that
that is fundamentally the thing that
almost every president up until trump
understood
is that that office is our the people's
office
you are just the placeholder that gets
to make the decisions in that office
while you're there
if we don't fire you
which we did the former guy
joe biden clearly understands
that he works for the american people
the american people do not work for him
it is crucially important that we
understand this fundamentally in our
democracy
because again i
again joe biden could have done more
maybe with student debt he could have
done a hell of a lot less
all the presidents before him did all
that less
none of them tried to cancel student
debt
not trump not obama not bush not clinton
not daddy bush
not reagan
here we have joe biden
using his power to cancel ten thousand
dollars of student debt
which some people aren't won't actually
get to take advantage i've paid off my
student debt
years ago so i don't get to take
advantage of this but that's okay it's
going to affect me positively
as the american working class gets to
have relief from this student debt that
will help all of us we are in this
together [ __ ]
even if we completely we are we are the
one of the problems here is we are in
this together even with the manga
terrorists
this is all our country we all live in
this [ __ ] space here
and the collective good is important and
that is why democracy
is the key
and why i believe that being
pro-democracy and staying pro-democracy
is absolutely absolutely 100 percent
going to deliver us one of these days a
better place of equity and equality now
democracy is tough that's the problem
and joe biden's gonna see a lot of
pushback today of democracy and how it's
tough because he didn't go far enough or
he went too far whatever the [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] the argument is that
this isn't good for america or it's not
good enough for america all these people
out there that are
that want all or nothing you dumb
[ __ ] a hundred percent of
nothing is nothing stupid ass
so today today pro-democracy people
pro-democracy people people who
fundamentally believe in equity and
equality and liberty for all
that they want to make sure this country
is doing what it can not not just big
government i'm talking about each other
you know i mean decency and empathy hmm
those are novel ideas
especially on the right
but decency and empathy prevails
and it delivers us some liberty do you
have any idea how much liberty this is
going to deliver to the american working
class
i don't know the exact numbers and i
don't need to know the exact numbers by
the way you don't need to know the exact
numbers
to know that this is not
a bad deal for america that this is a
really good [ __ ] sweet deal for the
american working class for families
there are people that are going to have
what is remaining of their student debt
wiped away
there are people out there that are
going to have
the majority of what is left of their
student debt wiped away
in a time in a time where we have record
low unemployment
our our wages are inflating
we have a record high economy as far as
the stock market is concerned
real estate in the last two years has
risen to a height that is unfathomable
at this point
we we are in a situation think about
this we are in a situation economically
where the democrats and only the
democrats delivered covet relief to the
american people in 2021 last year and
this year joe biden is relieving 10 000
of student debt to anyone who has
those non-pell grants
think about that for a second
in a time
in a time where we are doing well as an
american people and an american
president said that's not enough we need
more for the american working class
think about that think about the think
about the empathy and the decency that
it takes for an american president to do
that
he could say well we got record low
unemployment
you can afford to pay off your student
loans everyone's employed what do we
need to spend more government money for
why do we need to cancel more student
debt you have a job
pay your debt
he could be an [ __ ]
that's what that's what will happen
if we decide to put the fascist in
charge not only will they not cancel
student debt
they'll probably cancel
students altogether
they won't allow them to get educated in
this country
ron desantis is doing his damnedness to
do that down in florida
by the way we have a lot of election
news to get to today
also i have a great guest today at the
bottom of the hour adam epstein from the
dirty moderate i was on his show he's
been on here before he's going to join
us and we're going to talk about darth
vader jr
cheney
we'll talk about that
so we're gonna talk elections today i'm
i'm hoping adam is brushed up on his
elections so that we can talk elections
today
but we also have the [ __ ] list roundup
and then we'll carry the biden presser
uh after the sh at the top of the second
hour i believe it's supposed to be 2 15
eastern
if um someone could recheck that for me
now i was trying to get the show ready
and
i know we noticed that the press
conference and i think we're going to
carry that press conference
look this is very important in the time
that we're in
this contrast today
that you're going to see
and it's important not just in the
moment but it's important in american
history this is going to be a moment
that is going to be remembered for a
long time
and president biden is not is not it's
not going to be a knock on his
presidency
today marking the day that he canceled
student debt for american people when
american people were doing well
is going to be a mark in history that
people said
well he wasn't that bad of a president i
guess he cared about the american people
and we're going to be in a situation
where the contrast
of his opponent
who could have conceded after the
election after joe biden beat his ass by
8 million votes could have listened to
what the american people told him and to
[ __ ] off
100
could have done that
but he didn't he didn't [ __ ] off so much
so that he stole
criminally stole
our top secret documents he thinks
they're they're his by the way i guess
he's telling his lawyer get my documents
back get my documents back which i'm
going to talk about today i'm going to
talk about why i think he wants those
documents back so bad so [ __ ] bad why
does he want to back so goddamn bad
why
seems suspicious
seems suspicious
contrast these two moments
in history at this exact same time
contrast them of these two individuals
and how
we
in this country
avoided an absolute disaster
we avoided an absolute
disaster
it's super important
to look at this moment this exact day
and show
what the contrast was a guy who
it's gonna be really known as the most
crooked criminal american president that
we've ever seen
ever in our lifetimes and i don't know
that will i mean even if
even if we get a fascist like ron
desantis in there i don't know that
it'll be more criminal than this
[ __ ]
i have i i it's just
it's astounding it's astounding
how
unaware that he is so crooked and so
criminal
completely unaware
but in this moment do you think do you
think today
if if president trump was elected
that that [ __ ] would be doing
anything absolutely anything for the
american people do you do you think do
you think that would have happened
no
absolutely [ __ ] not not even a
goddamn chance good luck to you if you
believe that
good luck to you
but today the president united states
the person that the entire country went
well he is the better option
he is definitely the better option
because i don't believe 81 million
people voted for joe biden
i believe that 81 million people voted
against against grandpa poopypants for
the reasons that the news is the
headline 10a
and we see it over and over and over
again this row rage uh rachel
bittikoffer coined this this morning you
know rachel's a great friend of the show
she's a great political strategist my
favorite political strategist as you all
know i'm very i'm very biased towards my
favorite political strategist and rachel
bittikoffer if she's listening is my
favorite
political strategist i will not back
down from that she she tweeted this
morning about row rage and i thought oh
my god that's perfect
that's a perfect t-shirt row rage baby
forget blue wave row rage is way better
and we've seen that
now in the election
in the special election in new york's
19th
or i think i think his name is pat ryan
is that his name pat ryan
a veteran a democrat crushes
crushes his republican opponent
where
he was supposed to lose by 10 points
remember uh i think it was last week i
was telling you the polls are all
[ __ ]
remember that remember i was saying ah
these polls are [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah they're [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
believe them what you need to do
what you need to do
is to aim that road rage that strategic
outrage that you have that we deliver
here on the tony michaels podcast every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific you need to take that
road rage and that strategic outrage
and aim it towards the ballot
and engage in your democracy
it
is
important
if we cannot
if we cannot make sure
that we as as a people
as a government
stand for our way of life
then who will
who will you definitely aren't going to
see these republicans stand for our way
of life
jesus christ are all over the news this
morning
humping for the former guy and his
crimes
against our national security
this guy is threatening our national
security 100 percent full stop he is
[ __ ] threatening our national
security and that and that is the plain
dead truth of it
that's why they wanted them [ __ ]
documents back because he didn't have
proper authority to have him he did not
he did not go through the protocol to
have custody of him he stole them he
[ __ ] stole our top secret documents
they're not is they're not ears
[ __ ]
and then and we want them back we want
all of them back and we want to know
what the [ __ ] you did with them
we the people the government
and then you have joe biden the
president united states
who who 81 million people said he's the
better choice definitely
is proving today
today
in contrast
of the cheeto dust mobster in florida
he's proving the contrast we were
correct we were absolutely correct in
our assumption that he would be the
better person in charge of handling
the situation of holding our office of
the president of the united states
because clearly donald trump did not
understand what the president
the office of the president was nor what
he could and could not do and who or who
or who who is not
in charge of certain things
the contrast could not be starker today
and it's glorious
everyone knew this was going to happen
everyone knew this was going to happen
that this was going to be the situation
that donald trump would absolutely
implode
and it's going to get worse i mean it
keeps getting worse every [ __ ] day i
mean first it was 300 now at 700
occupants now this morning it's top
secret dogs and he's crying to his staff
and his lawyers to get him back he tries
to file a motion to shop a criminal
judge
that's not how that [ __ ] works and
the judge knows it
the judge is like um this statement is
written in crown and you're at the wrong
court my friend
that's i mean not in so many words i
mean the judge understands what's going
on the judge isn't [ __ ] stupid
and the judge is basically saying hey
this is not correct and by the way i'm
not the judge that you want to file this
with
just so you know
it it really is [ __ ] crazy especially
on the heels of an election yesterday
where folks like laura loomer get slam
dunked holy [ __ ]
laura loomer and nick fuentes the
holocaust denier
the nazi nick fuentes the america first
nazi
marjorie taylor greene's best friend
nick fuentes
they cheers as she's going to win then
she loses and oh my god it's oh it's
it's a beautiful piece of content
it's a beautiful piece of content and
here's why
she is absolutely sobbing
sobbing
that she lost and there's no way that it
even could be fathomable that
there's election fraud to this extent
that she could lose and she's there
they're really trying hard they're
really i mean you gotta hand it to them
they're really trying to har they're
trying hard to sell that their
republicans are even stealing elections
now think about this for a second think
about the position that they're in and
the continuation of this election fraud
stupidity absolute [ __ ] stupidity
as we get news that another person from
the villages is is [ __ ] guilty of
voting two or three or ten times for
trump
the actual voter fraud that happened you
know
trump's side trump supporters
but think about this for a second
think about how important these
elections last night are when these
people are gonna go out and scream that
the republicans
are now the ones who are committing
committing election fraud do you think
they're based do you think their people
are going to trust them all to handle an
election jesus christ how could we how
could we
how could we trust anyone
with our economy if we can't even trust
him with the primary election and laura
loomer's district i mean those
republicans are horrible
politicize everything folks save our
democracy and this morning
celebrate celebrate that we have an
american president who is for the
american people not for himself
not for himself not not just for a
certain class of people in this country
but he's been and trying to deliver for
the american people the best way that he
can now i mean i'm not saying he's
perfect i know i actually don't believe
that joe biden will be hailed as the
greatest president of all time
but he certainly he certainly is he
certainly
is trying to do the best that he can for
the people who voted for him the 81
million people i think more than
anything the contrast today that you
should draw from the news and the
headlines is that joe biden
is trying his best
to advance our democracy
for the american people and donald trump
grandpa poopypants
is trying his best to undermine it with
him and his supporters don't forget we
air live every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
for two full hours
two full hours every single weekday on
youtube twitter and twitch
so don't forget to follow us here and
subscribe
to the youtube channel the tony michaels
podcast also follow us on twitter at
tony michael's pod tomorrow's thursday
and we vote for bonehead of the week we
do bonehead of the week to all the new
listeners we do bonehead of the week
every single week
we put out a poll you vote you decide
we break down your decision the winner
of the bonehead of the week every single
friday in the second hour of the tony
michaels podcast so don't miss every
single friday
the bonehead of the week in the second
hour special announcement about bonehead
of the week
we are going to air bonehead of the week
friday evening we're not sure the exact
time but friday evening we'll be airing
bonehead of the week on the midas touch
youtube channel you can also download
bonehead of the week
on all your
favorite directories apple spotify
google
but this week will be the very first
week that we air bonehead of the week on
the midas touch youtube channel so don't
forget to go over to the minus touch
network and subscribe also subscribe
here while you're here
we will be over there the the bone as we
can watch it live here or you can go to
the mind is touch
network and you can watch it
friday nights we're not sure of the time
yet we're working out the time we'll be
announcing that so go subscribe and
click the bell notifications here and
at the minus touch youtube channel so
you do not miss a single video
folks we're i'm i'm supposed to have
adam epstein here from the dirty
moderate
uh very soon
so don't go anywhere stick around right
after the break we will be right back
right after these messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99
actual partying is not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome
welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break
oh baby did we have elections last night
i hope our next guest has
done his research this morning done his
own research on the facebook
about the elections last night
he's been on our show before i've
actually been on his show the dirty
moderate with adam epstein adam epstein
is going to be joining us soon
i can't wait to talk to him i i really
here's the thing
me and him agree and disagree on darth
vader jr this is this is liz cheney i
called liz cheney darth vader jr we
agreed to disagree on a few things but i
think we agree on a few things and i
wanted to sort that out with adam on on
on the show here i wanted to sort it out
exactly what we agree on what we don't
agree on
and i want to find some common ground
with a dirty moderate to to be quite
honest with you um he's been on the show
before you know him as the dirty
moderate adam epstein adam how are you
the dirty moderate is here tony i'm
always happy to see you hey
it's great it's great that you came to
talk to us about um darth vader jr but
first i want to uh get some business out
of the way here yeah it seems that the
elections last night um spoke loudly in
several areas uh new york's 19th i think
his name is pat ryan ryan yeah he's a
democrat he's a veteran um he was it
looked like he was about eight to ten
points down in the polls
in the polls prior to the election uh he
was he was poised to lose and last night
he won
big if you consider how much the polls
said he was down i guess my question is
this because that i think that is a big
reminder of what uh rachel bittikov has
called this morning row rage
over this decision of jobs
but what do you think about these polls
because i said last week i think the
polls are are way off um i don't know if
the the methods are antiquated or it's
the questions that they're asking or who
they're asking but they seem to be way
off with the kansas and now new york's
19th kansas with their no vote on the
referendum for
bodily autonomy for women
and now in new york's 19th they just
seem to be way off what's your take on
this well first of all i want to
congratulate pat ryan uh keeping that
hudson valley district it's a real
bellwether right that tells you um how
the politics are going i mean that was a
district that obama carried in uh
12
that
uh trump got narrowly uh in 16 and then
biden won narrowly in 20. so first of
all it is a very important omen to look
at swing races and and and take data out
of that
the second part of my answer is i think
the effects of dobbs easily i think the
worst supreme court decision since maybe
dred scott versus sanford you know i
mean is
is has galvanized
not just women tony and this speaks to
sort of where i come from a lot of
independent or independent leaning women
even republican-leaning women
never thought that this would happen
right meaning that that they really
thought that they could vote for let's
say in the old days quaint times and
mitt romney or john mccain and you know
for fiscal reasons other reasons but
abortion wouldn't be ultimately taken
away that has proven itself demonstrably
false the religious right and the
right-wing nut jobs in tandem with maga
now for the last six years have created
a court
and an environment where that has
happened uh also the states the red
states they're going to try to do and
already doing horrible things like
banning abortion places like indiana and
idaho and stuff like that
i think row rage is real and i think
that though people are concerned about
inflation and gas and all of that
it's coming down
um i think biden seems stronger than he
that he seemed i don't know that uh his
approval rating will jack up all that
much but i think you might see a year
where uh president's approval rating
isn't great um but uh certainly the
senate uh remains blue and maybe gets
increased and perhaps
the house goes blue perhaps i only say
that because it's such a narrow majority
and there's been so much gerrymandering
on the right that i think
the republicans could still hold it
narrowly i hate to say that um but it's
possible they won't it's possible given
the new york the evidence of new york's
19th last night that we're going to see
uh uh that kind of 5248 in those purple
districts it's kind of that's what i
call it right a kind of democratic
edging out because moderates
democratic moderates people like me who
might have not me but i mean i might
have been inclined to the new yorker i
used to live in new york i used to vote
for new york republicans i wouldn't this
year you know what i mean because i
don't want to give these people another
seat to create gilead
quite frankly so hi gabe hey
so anyway yeah gabe is joining us here
and um
adam i i think you're i think you're
right on
i i will i will push back a little bit
in that i think last night is is uh hard
evidence that that that the democrats
are actually in the lead in the house
and i and me and gabe have talked about
how these i hope you're right i said i
really hope i'm rooting for it i i mean
i i just i just know that with the
narrowness of the majority the math may
not
in other words there may be too many
safe republican seats
to overcome
a to win a majority meaning the purples
the purple districts that are all up for
grabs there's about 25 of them i think
the majority of them will go blue if
alabama for example now has three
completely gerrymandered seats because
they put all black people in one
district to do that on purpose the
courts threw out the challenges they
have three seats they don't deserve
right there right you saw them saying
it's a guaranteed republican seat people
say alabama no if if there could have
been swing districts in alabama they
just gerrymander them out does that make
sense well yeah well and i mean i think
i think the republicans um whole point
in the gerrymandering and in the census
was to cheat to win yeah i i don't i
don't think they were successful at
gerrymandering in some states like they
wanted to be
alabama is an example where they were
pretty successful in that effort um and
hopefully
hopefully we can do things to make sure
to save our democracy and give alabama
an actual voice in our house or
representatives because they when when
they when you actually gerrymander
things like that um what you do is you
take away the voice of the state right
and alabama
now now has less representation in the
house of representatives they may think
they have more because now we have more
republicans but alabama as a state has
less of a voice inside that chamber
in the overall scheme of democracy now
speaking of house races yes and safe
house races there's one in particular
that i want to talk to you about of
course um i think it's in the state of
the wyoming has two senators but they
only have one
house representative because of their
population size now you endorsed liz
cheney dirty moderate um i i actually
wanted her to win that uh primary race
she lost her primary words yeah um
i i think actually she's better
positioned um if she would like to take
power in the party where she's at by
losing that primary race i know that
sounds weird um but i think in the in
the actual political body that we have
now that she actually now is poised to
be the leader of what could be the old
guard gop um because of how that race
went now i call her darth vader jr and i
obviously have very strong opinions
about liz cheney but tell us why you
endorsed her maybe we can find some
common ground here
why you're a liz jenny fan well i mean i
think you first of all you know um i've
been on your program before you've been
on mine and i think you and gabe both
know my main cause is fighting for
democracy okay we say it dirty moderate
saving democracy one episode at a time
that is the paramount issue right now
tony the republican party as it stands
as a threat to democracy america our
freedoms our rights and everything okay
so
there are in regions of the country like
wyoming alaska's another one with
murkowski who i also endorsed
a democrat is not going to win in that
seat right so we have to start from that
the question then is who is the
republican in office that would you know
take up the mantle not for republicanism
democrats or even independents but
actually believe in democracy not be a
seditious [ __ ] like these people
are okay
that was liz cheney clearly she got
blown out of the water because the
party's left her you know it's a trump
publican party that's what it is when
people say trump you know it's not his
party he's gone he's not gone he's very
much in the news he's actually
dominating the news cycle with his um
crimes of course but it's still but it's
but it i i think it's important to say
who is going to stand up for democracy
first and foremost and i know your
listeners and you and i don't put words
in anybody's mouth you don't have issues
with their voting record number one
democracy trumps all so when people keep
saying
well i disagree with this channel and
everything but
i go you really kind of respectfully i
say you have it backwards there's no but
meaning in an authoritarian government
none of the things that anybody want
that most of us want certainly to the
left wants are gonna happen if if if we
have president desantis and governor
mostriano and all these people you know
what i mean and harriet hageman none of
it so the first order of business is
securing the democracy and liz does want
to do that one can take issue with her
voting record i don't agree with her on
everything i think i agree with her more
than you guys do but i certainly don't
agree with her and everything but that's
okay in a democracy because that's who
we are what's not okay is lying about an
election undermining the constitution uh
and actually perpetuating the belief
that the free fair transfer of power
didn't exist in 2020 right i mean it is
outrageous that we're still talking
about this ronald reagan called the
peaceful transfer of power a miracle
that it's a blessing of our democracy
ronald reagan wouldn't get the
nomination of this party i mean it's
obscene so to me
apart from the whether i agree with liz
cheney or not i always just feel like
i'm putting country first and i don't
want harriet hayek i mean and those are
my choices it wasn't liz cheney and um
uh
who would it be i'm trying to think of
something liz cheney where someone i
would like liz cheney and um
uh alyssa slotnick in michigan or
something you know what i mean somebody
who's like a moderate abigail spanger in
virginia that wasn't the choice you're
talking about an old line constitutional
conservative and then a total [ __ ]
whack job i call her miss trunchville
from matilda but i probably shouldn't
actually look like and you got matilda
she was a miss trunchbull right well
here's my pushback here's my pushback
and i and i and i i want to be clear
that i think we agree on a lot of things
here but we fundamentally disagree on on
one thing and that is the one seat in
wyoming and why that one seat doesn't
[ __ ] matter in the grand scheme of
things and it doesn't matter if harriet
harriet weirdo whack-a-doo lunatic has
it or liz cheney and here's why okay
because those two people are going to
vote almost the exact same way
i know i know that i know that feels
like it's insignificant but that
fundamentally is the reason why they are
sent
to the house of representatives is to
vote for those people of wyoming and in
the grand scheme of things
liz cheney in my opinion is much better
position now politically to take control
of the party than if she was the
representative from wyoming now she is
now she is the person who is going to
absolutely throw dirt on trump's
political grave here i mean she's missed
it all i mean you have to give her
credit yeah no well and here's here's
what i'll say about this by the way let
me interrupt you for a quick i apologize
the one thing i haven't done that i
think i've seen my liberal friends do
because they're excited is lionize her
in other words why don't lionize any
politician
the reason i hate trump cultism is
presidents are not kings politicians are
not rock stars i don't like i hate that
people are like yay you know brandon got
the gas prices down he did not he didn't
raise them and he didn't get them down
and i'm a supporter joe biden let's not
do what they do let's not let's not be
cultists anyway go ahead right no no so
so here's what i'll say about um
about liz cheney yeah darth vader jr is
that the voting record it didn't matter
who was going to win that race it was
either if liz cheney won she was going
to win the seat right if harriet lunatic
wins the carrie lakewish.com carrie lake
wins that she's going to win that seat
and they're going to vote almost the
exact same way so the results on the
house floor exactly the same here's the
difference here's the biggest difference
to me
is that um harriet lunatic is not going
to be taken seriously at all
um she's actually going to be ostracized
and probably a pariah
within a matter of by the end of her
two-year uh term at the house of
representatives i believe that the the
people in wyoming are smart enough to
understand
when when they do see the results that
she doesn't get them um i do i think
they'll say that was a [ __ ] mistake
and the reason why it was a mistake is
because we played into this she's
against us thing because i don't think
liz cheney necessarily aim is for
democracy i actually believe
that liz cheney's aim rather rather it
gives us the actual results that we want
as pro-democracy people or not because
the way she votes
the what she is for
is not exactly liberal democracy it's
not exactly that way and i and and i
know i know i know that's a hard pill to
kind of swallow sometimes that there are
people who will want to hail as heroes
because i want to say she's a hero but
she's not and the reason why she's not
is because she would do almost the exact
same things that trump did
besides maybe some of the crimes and
besides the crime against our democracy
because she knows it's a threat to her
power um but i do want to say and i do
want to give her credit here
when she is absolutely carrying the
shovel that will bury trumpism yeah but
um when she actually took the family
backhoe away from her dad to bury
trumpism and that ad that he put out
darth vader himself um to absolutely and
i don't think it was a rally cry around
liz cheney i think that ad more than
anything was a statement to republicans
all around the country and it was a
warning that hey
if you are attached to trump and you're
not attached to the cheney train
you're going to lose politically very
bad and you're not going to have a party
i believe that's what the message was
and the reason why is because dick
cheney was the only republican other
than his daughter who stood on the house
floor yep on january 6 2022
this year
to actually give remembrance to the
people who lost their lives and the
people who fought a battle against the
trump supporters who tried to create on
violent insurrection to overthrow our
vote they were the only two republicans
standing there with nancy pelosi which
is unheard of is unheard of that that
two republicans would stand there so
i agree with you that i think liz cheney
appears to be for democracy um
everything everything would say that she
does want our democracy to survive so
that she can retain power inside of her
own republican party that is the way
that i think that is actually going on i
don't actually think that she wants a
full equality full equity she doesn't
want bodily autonomy for women it's
obvious she said it she doesn't actually
want to have um
sweeping voting reform to make sure
people have complete hundred percent
access to the ballot she doesn't want
those things um so to say that she is
for democracy
she may be but it's a different type of
democracy than what i think most people
are thinking of in this country at this
moment in history right i mean she's for
the survival i mean to be clear she's
for the survival of the country as well
but
let me let me say something and you know
you may not like this and no go ahead no
no and the listeners may not like this
as an independent it gives me even if i
were a democrat it gives me no joy to
see the moral and philosophical collapse
of the party of lincoln what i mean by
that is i do not want to live we are a
two-party country i do not want to live
in a country that is all a dem there's
run entirely by democrats for the rest
of my life i just don't we need a center
right alternative that is not
kooka-dooka luca whack-a-doodle okay
that aren't election deniers that aren't
fraudsters that yeah are gonna be more
right-wing than the democrats are and i
don't mean always far-right wing they're
just going to be more conservative on
the spectrum
to balance it out we are about a tension
in our democracy but we have to compete
for ideas and while i'm not here to
vouch for liz cheney there is a
honorable strain of constitutional
conservatism that for a place like
wyoming and i i don't think first of all
you put everything together i reject
that argument but not to say you know
everything is not voting and right it is
but let me say this let me pull
something out the people who are
ranchers in wyoming want the federal
government to leave them the [ __ ] alone
and they're right they don't want to be
taxed by washington it's i don't
understand why people can't understand
in the same way by the way that people
in blue cities and states you know what
i mean don't want red states dictating
their values to them we're still a
50-state country and i believe that and
i believe somebody can be sent to
washington with a different
philosophical bent i disagree with liz
cheney on a lot of things but i don't
disagree with her on everything because
i think she was representing her
district and i don't have to agree with
people to have this democracy to survive
and i know that's you know i'm not
listen i am voting blue and i do like
joe biden and i i've actually never
voted for republican for president but i
also know that we have to have a healthy
republican party or we are doomed if
because and i'm just saying this to you
authoritarianism isn't owned by the
right history shows that and i don't
mean that if the democrats stay in power
all of a sudden gonna have like a stalin
government
but what i mean is what i'm pointing out
is absolutely right you're saying
brandon's a communist that's what you're
saying that's what i hear you know i'm
just kidding
i'm saying that i'm saying that um
absolute power corrupts absolutely uh
you see it in i'm sorry you see it in
california you see it in blue states
where there's no check on the power you
see in red states you see it in what's
happening in missouri you see what's
happening in idaho you see in places
where forces blue voters but it's like
they're doing every crazy thing they can
do and i like a government which finds
itself kind of wobbling in the middle i
think that's the best place to be by the
way that doesn't mean there's no
progress it means progress is moderated
with reality that's what that's the way
i i i i think we find common ground here
because gabe me and you talked about on
this show that really we i think the the
the actual
tension that we have in the country is
we don't have two parties we actually
have a party who hates democracy who
wants to destroy it and we have a lot of
people who disagree on all sorts of
[ __ ] things
right yeah well the other thing i think
too to remember is like you know if you
were to look at the country as if it was
a company right and you have a let's say
a
uh in that company you have a team right
you would never want a team that is
fully on one side or at least and when i
say that i mean like you want to make
sure that your team is diverse in the
way that we approach different ideas
experiences anecdotes what have you
right like we can't have a completely
right team that's crazy we can have a
completely left team that
is one way or the other is crazy i mean
there are crazy people on both sides
it's a spectrum right
um
but having the ability to come you know
across the aisle crazy idea these days
considering the way that the parties are
kind of so polarized but you know if we
look at it like a an actual team right
the the the companies or the board
members or whoever you want to describe
them as that are more successful are the
ones that come from
a very different background because they
can approach problems from different
experiences maybe one time it's more
left it's more right like
obviously right now we have seen
the country want to get away at least
the people who are more sane and kind of
logical thinking to get away from the
crazy right
because that side is what is
deteriorating the company from within
it's like you know it's the definition
of insanity right you're doing the same
thing over and over again expecting
different results and we've seen that in
the last five years from this side of
the right who have done everything that
is i mean even today right like
doing 20 to 10 to 20k in in student loan
forgiveness we've got people on the left
who aren't happy we've got people on the
right who are definitely not happy and i
think it's great i think that's right it
is great because it's great for the
american working class right
why why is it not great i mean that's
the thing and that's where and my i'm
all my progressive friend they love that
because i'm for that i'm for universal
healthcare i said yeah because i each
issue to me is not i'm not i don't need
to buy the entire
uh kate you know what i mean gabe i
don't really have an entire package i am
able to have i have an a la carte
politics i really think and that's
to my point earlier look you guys know
this and those who follow me i'm a gay
guy i don't want anybody who's going to
fight against lgbtq equality that's
nobody should want that but certainly i
would never vote against my own humanity
but i like a party and i and maybe this
is the growing pains that does
fundamentally believe maybe they're the
lincoln party in voting rights and in
human rights and all those things and
then we can have a debate like the
before times we get all that out of the
way no one's deciding that women don't
have a right to their bodies no one's
deciding telling trans kids they can't
have gender affirming surgery all this
crap that they're trying to to just to
divide us on and to really hurt people
but then i really do want to have a
debate about
limited government or larger government
what we should do in terms of national
defense how we should do that uh what is
the role what kind of tax rate should we
have but these are these are luxuries
almost now because the other side
literally to cling to power is willing
to burn the american experiment but that
would be my dream in politics because i
as a independent would like to say well
yeah listen i really like what joe biden
has done 75 of the time i don't have to
like every single thing but yes i still
like the president i support him and
that's okay do you know what i mean but
i don't like in our politics and i by
the way i'm never both sightseeing
because
the left is [ __ ] crazy but i don't
think they're dangerous like the right
you know what i mean i think there's we
have to differentiate well how dare they
want to fix the climate and build decent
roads and high speed rail those are
dangerous things
make sure to make sure that you don't go
bankrupt when you have a medical bill
that's dangerous type [ __ ] to make sure
that your student debt is a situation
where you can survive and support a
family because that's what you went to
college for in the first place that's
dangerous type stuff that's dangerous
stuff i know it's dangerous
i know well that's that's why it's a
it's a what about ism i don't like but
what about but what i would say is is i
do think there are legitimate debates to
be had about how to govern that actually
do help people you know what i mean
there are many instances where
and remember i'm a good faith actor but
i'm not coming at this with some i'm not
some reagan republican who's like trying
to like you know
you know you're trying to pull a jedi
mind drinking i mean i like you're right
i'm not here but here's what i'll say
here's what i'll say because because i i
think i get what you're saying but i
think i think our political body in this
country is is not two parties anymore
it's not it's not republican and
democrat it's not conservative and
liberal and here's why let me let me
show you this video here please this is
this is this is darth vader himself
we were talking about earlier
a guy that i loathed all those years i
never voted for them you know well
listen listen to what this guy says one
more time because i think this piece of
content is super important inside of
what america is going through right now
let's listen
246 history there has never been an
individual who is a greater threat to
our republic than donald trump he tried
to steal the last election using lies
and violence to keep himself in power
after the voters had rejected him
he was a coward a real man wouldn't lie
to his supporters he lost his election
and he lost big
i know it he knows it and deep down i
think most republicans know it
lynn and i are so proud of liz for
standing up for the truth doing what's
right
honoring her oath to the constitution
when so many our party are too scared to
do so
liz is fearless she never backs down
from a fight there is nothing more
important she will ever do
then lead the effort to make sure donald
trump is never again near the oval
office okay so i'll cut it short there
because then he goes into phenomena
i wish
a guy like me has always yearned for the
[ __ ] ruthless cold-eyed cowboy to use
his macho [ __ ] for good no i mean you
know what i mean usually those kind of
guys are the guys that like trans people
are coming your neighborhood right right
this guy you know i mean i love i'm not
i hate to give dick cheney any credit
but i love that he is what he said never
in 246 years the guy's a coward you know
it deep down they know it i just
think about that but think about that
for a second adam yeah because i think
he's telling us he's telling us that
there's not two parties right now
there's not two parties you're
pretending that you're against democracy
even if even if you
know and believe deep down inside of you
that donald trump's a crook and he's a
criminal and he tried he tried to steal
our demo i don't care who tried to
destroy the heart government who the
[ __ ] you are he tried to take your way
of life regardless if you like him love
him whatever the [ __ ] you worship him
you wear clothes with his face on it or
you [ __ ] hate him he tried to steal
your way of life and i think that's what
dick cheney is actually saying in this
tape and i think more than that he's
saying because i i think
liz cheney dick cheney knew that she was
probably going to lose
and this video
is a a launch and her losing is a launch
of her presidential campaign against
trump if he would decide to run um and i
think that's what i want to leave it on
i want to ask you since we're talking
about darth vader and darth vader jr
because i think this is an interesting
topic
is
does liz cheney does she run for
president
only if donald trump runs or does she
run uh if ron desantis runs she kind of
tow ron desantis a couple weeks ago to
to go [ __ ] himself yeah she said he's
not so many right so so i don't know if
she's setting up to where she's gonna
run against any trumpism or just trump
himself what do you think
i
i only think i can answer because i
don't have enough knowledge i don't
think anybody does but i mean my most
informed speculation says
that
don't [ __ ] with the cheneys okay
and no i really i mean you know like
them or don't like them don't [ __ ] with
them and they despise what trump has
done to the republican party right to
your point too it doesn't make them
angels but i also think it does make
them villains um
they
i think liz would like to exact revenge
and i think she means it when she says
which to me is my rallying cry we all
have to do everything we can to make
sure that unfit piece of [ __ ] bargain
basement mussolini never gets anywhere
near the white house again and that goal
to me and i by the way i apply the same
thing to ron desantis i think he's a
dangerous
lunatic and smarter too a much smarter
lunatic but
trump is still in the forefront and i
think that yeah she could run
against him to sort of make it a harder
run i mean i know there's and then
there's a lot of talk about would she
run as an independent and what would
that mean
that needs to be looked at you know i
mean i always for originally said well
she would ross peroham you know how ross
perot helped bill clinton get elected in
92
took 19 of the vote from bush but then
would she pull swing voters away and
hurt the democrat i don't know we don't
know that but i i she knows she's not
going to be elected because she can't
get the republican nomination she
obviously can't get the democratic
nomination so but she
she might do it to to cause ruckus
because i actually think
in in the way that um
in the way that she's been fighting for
democracy apart from however she's voted
she does want yeah she does want a
conservative republican party but she
wants one that's not tainted by lies and
deceit i do i do think that and i think
that's what she'd like to get back to
does that mean she gets more power of
course but politics is about power i
mean if we're going to talk about who
democrats want you know what i mean i
mean look at they're all lining up to
run power is inherent and i don't
criticize them for that that's part of
the game you know right you have to have
power to set policy yeah i mean you know
whenever they say oh so and so is
presidential ambitions
well if they're popular in politics and
beloved and in the senate or higher yeah
of course as opposed to what i mean
i mean you know they're not running for
the you know to me to the head of
radiology at a hospital i mean they're
trying
adam adam i think maybe we should elect
our radiologist at the hospital give us
give us one last push i wanna i wanna
hear i wanna hear a shameless plug from
you tell the audience where they can
find adam epstein the dirty moderate
with admins where can they find it all
right you can you can find our podcast
anywhere you get your podcasts we're
everywhere apple google spotify
amazon you know the whole list we are at
twitter uh at dirtymoderate on twitter i
also my personal account overlaps with
that it's at adam epstein prod so those
are my twitter accounts and then
instagram of course where i try to keep
a viable presence is at dirty moderate
and at the real adam epstein so i know i
just gave you a lot but no
go go follow adam adam on the socials
the socials the socials you know the
the grammy grams and the tweety tweets
that's what they are here that's what
they are here uh you know gabe makes fun
of me because i'm a boomer that's what
he says
actually i think you called me a
hillbilly in the temple yeah last night
because you're like my internet's not
working yeah my internet was down
my internet was down yesterday so
apparently us in the hills us and the
sticks
get called hillbilly when we now i will
say adam just for the record my internet
is held a lot better than gabe's when it
is up and running when it is up and
running wow you know
the internet against high you know
high-speed internet out here in l.a very
red state there
i don't know
let me allow me also generosity of
spirit uh tony i love being on your show
i love when you come on my show gabe i
love your comedy and all your posts they
i live for them kind of they're amazing
they'll both you're amazing stuff so i
love being in touch with you guys and
appearing and don't get his head too big
don't get it
thanks thanks adam for joining us
everyone go follow the dirty moderate
with adam epstein on anywhere where you
find your podcast and i think we can
agree on one thing let's not take the
shovel out of liz cheney's hand as she's
digging the grave for trumpism adam
thank you for joining us everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking to the break adam epstein
dirty moderate i don't think we'll ever
fully agree on darth vader jr
i think we found a little bit of common
ground there
go check out adam's podcast the dirty
moderate maybe i'll maybe i'll make my
way back you should go on the dirty
moderate too we should pimp you for the
dirty bite hey you know i'll do whatever
yeah well you know
you got to make sure your head's big
over here you put myself around like he
like make he like making your head big
maybe you could go over there
uh what do you what do you think of that
argument about liz cheney that adam
so i
in my personal opinion i think that liz
cheney is uh
more of a force and can be more used as
more of a tool than her
in her current position right like she
has she has the power to do what she can
within the jan6 committee
but i think outside of her role i i kind
of look at in similar ways to when
someone is elected president right the
president only has so much power right
and then you have to rely on the power
of your own party as you know assuming
that you have the majority kind of rule
to get laws passed or legislation passed
that you can sign but for the most part
a president you know is kind of like uh
it's just like a a
a talking head in some ways in regards
to like
you know you ha again you have to rely
on your party to pass the legislation
for you to actually sign it into law
so
i look at that as the possibility that
if liz cheney is let loose from her role
as a representative then she could
potentially have more power
and more resources to go after people
like trump and the rest of them within
that party
because i mean like if you look at what
happened last year she got kicked out of
the party and if you're comparing
representatives of people who are like
toxic
or or just uh overall uh dangerous for
the party of the of republicans you've
got uh matt gates who just won his
primary right he's going against um
rebecca jones who is the covid uh
whistleblower in in florida and then
you've got people like margaret she's
someone that got her door kicked in
right right exactly and and then turns
out she was right right she wasn't lying
about the numbers being manipulated and
kind of massaged by desantis and the
rest of the party to make florida seem
better than it was and then you've got
other people like marjorie taylor green
who just last night was like oh at 1 am
my house was swatted right now whether
that was true or not i don't know i
can't wait to get the footage of that
can you
but she's someone you know like these
two people are are are just [ __ ]
insane right like you look at like who
is more destructive matt gates lauren
bober marger taylor green or liz cheney
like i have to agree that liz cheney is
probably not as destructive as these
other three people who are pushing a
very far right agenda and i totally
agree with what you were saying earlier
is that her voting record yes does align
with trump but i feel like she does
believe more in a in a pro-democracy she
doesn't want this far-right fascist
regime coming in and she's willing to
put her career and her reputation on the
line which we've seen with the jan six
committee and what she did with you know
what her platform that she's running on
so i think that at the end of the day
her position and her power could be
better utilized as an independent
citizen right someone who's able to
you know pull in resources and funding
and put a team together and maybe go
against and help she said she was going
to help democrats run right didn't she
say she was going to campaign with them
in terms of getting people that were
in in uh in office that were running
against these trumpists
uh well i mean i think she's going to do
everything she can to to bury trump and
and again i don't i do not agree with
what she says so right well
here's the here's the thing with
she's going to do everything she can to
bury trumpism because ultimately at the
like we were saying at the end with adam
there is it's all about power i mean and
and her play for power here is to be the
anti-trump and the the savior of
anti-trump and she knows that she's
going to carry along a lot of people who
have abandoned the republican party who
have come to the pro-democracy side and
who are probably going to vote for a lot
of democrats as long as they're
pro-democracy and i think she she sees
herself as someone who can play to that
moderate right that that that
independent side and that's why we need
to be careful because i don't think
she's a moderate i don't think she's an
independent i don't think she's a
liberal in the sense that she views
democracy the way that liberal
small l liberal democracy is supposed to
be viewed i actually don't think she
views it that way and not that she wants
to destroy democracy she just wants to
use it for her type of game um there are
fascists out there who absolutely want
to destroy it like donald trump like
nick fuentes nick fuentes appeared last
night with laura loomer did you see this
what's funny about this is laura loomer
um
she she is anti-muslim because she
thinks they're all she's like [ __ ]
crazy right and then and then she hangs
out with uh anti-semites nazis like nick
fuentes which is absolutely crazy so we
had a lot of election news last night we
did have uh matt gatz win his primary
but we had a lot of a lot of wins the
biggest win i think is this well i don't
think it's a big win i think it's a big
tell i think it's a big uh i don't know
i guess you could say doubt me we got
these shirts now that say doubt me and
last week we were talking about those we
were talking about how the polls were
all [ __ ] and doubt me on this just
doubt me on that these polls are just
[ __ ] nonsense they're antiquated and
they're not they're not the way that
they should be go to
store.thetonymichaels.com to get your
doubt me merch or you can go to the
tonymichaels.com the link is there in
the bio so go get your doubt me shirts
uh stickers coffee mugs and hoodies over
there on the merch store but doubt me on
this about these polls because
new york's 19th was way the [ __ ] off i
mean way the [ __ ] off because how many
points did he win by are they saying
that this morning how many points he's
actually seen i know that he was
projected to lose by eight to ten points
sorry well it it was
they had it ten but i think with the
margin of error is like eight
and eight wait the margin of error was
eight well no no no no i mean i'm saying
with the margin oh got it gigger and the
margin of error man nobody's big in the
margin air is like eight percent or
twelve percent you know but that's why
they came at ten percent but still ten
percent is a big [ __ ] number yeah
that's a big
in 2020
narrowly won that like adam said by two
percent
right that's not a huge win for biden
because that is a swing district
that's a swing
if anything it tells you you know
polling is
inherently flawed right right you've
talked about it before you know
depending i think i think it's
antiquated how they're doing it still
yeah right like i don't you know i would
have to go through to read how different
uh
different companies are doing their
polling you know and and what their
methodology is but i think for the most
part like you're like oh you know did we
have we called this person like again
i've never been texted i've never been
called i've never got an email so i
don't know what part of the country
where they're pulling from you know it
where you know who they're who they're
you know anonymously pulling from in
terms of their party affiliation on the
the voter roster um but i've never been
contacted that way so i don't even know
what that experience is like right even
even i've never even been pulled on like
a consumer survey
for when they're doing like um
they're saying oh this is how you know
so and so responded to this tv show or
this consumer product or whatever i've
never been in that category before so i
don't know exactly how that goes i've
conducted polls on my own
um through with companies that i've
worked for
but i've never actually been on the
receiving end of one so i don't know you
know who's being contacted but i mean if
anything
the polls this season right this this
primary season as we lead up to the
midterms definitely showed you it's been
a swing it's been a hit or a miss right
like there is no consistency to say
that this group has been more accurate
than this group or it has been able to
say like oh yeah this democrat is
definitely going to win or this
republican is definitely going to win or
this uh
you know this law is you know that is on
the ballot is definitely going to be
approved or not approved right like i
feel like there's so much inconsistency
that the polls are like
it's just like it's just like the guy
shrugging the emoji it's just like i
don't know it could it could not
um i think other areas are more apparent
depending on how your district is laid
out and and how it has and has voted in
the past but even that might come into
question
when um you've got people kind of like
breaking through some of these these
local state elections so
what we're going to we're going to see a
contrast here today
um gabe inside of our country and our
democracy because not only the contrast
to what some of these elections told us
last night because i think it's more
than evidence i think it's apparent that
there is road rage in this country
because they know that these republicans
are trying to take away their rights and
their liberty and fundamentally unwind
democracy for their own you know
for their own ideological
means through white christian
nationalism and this america first nazi
party but here's what i'll say today is
going to be a stark difference because
we're going to watch the president
united states do something that no other
president has had the guts to do yeah
and may never have the guts to do again
who knows um to actually do something
for the working middle class during a
time where we have the lowest
unemployment any president in history
could look at his country and say i'm
not gonna cancel your student debt you
all got jobs right you all got jobs go
[ __ ] pay for your own student debt
right but he's not doing that he's
keeping a campaign promise he's doing
something for the american people which
i think is important and in contrast in
contrast we have a federal judge down in
in florida saying to the former
president who has committed crimes
apparently by stealing our top secret
documents from our government she's like
um
this is written in crown and i'm not the
correct judge so let's get to the [ __ ]
list round up because gabe you got a lot
of [ __ ] to round up in the tweety tweets
in the trendy trend so let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the [ __ ] list roundup
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends all the happenings
of today
on twitter a lot going on today because
of last night and this morning one of
the main things is this here joe biden
has released this student debt loan uh
plan they're going to be doing a press
conference gabe we're going to hold this
thing live after the show so don't go
anywhere at the top of the hour we're
not we're going to stay right here so
we're going to simulcast um here on
youtube twitter twitch also on the midas
touch facebook page but we will go live
here on this broadcast this one right
here on the midas touch youtube channel
as soon as we get to the top of the hour
here in about 45 minutes i think his
press conference is supposed to start
about 2 15. he'll probably speak around
2 30 eastern time somewhere between 2 15
and 2 30 eastern so stick around but
here is that plan that he's going to
talk about today because um mainly it's
the 10 000 that i think a lot of people
are talking about this morning because
you get ten thousand dollars of student
debt forgiveness meaning you just get it
wiped from the books if you didn't
receive uh pell grants now if you did
receive pell grants um
it's 20. so in other words now you know
what pell grants are right yeah i'm a
recipient of pell grants so you you did
receive so pell grants are normally uh
given to folks who are not as
i don't know what's the correct word
that i want to use here i mean the
correct way to describe it is like you
don't make a certain amount of income
your household so you fall so you're not
mitt romney do you remember mitt romney
said you know if you want to go to
college just borrow a million dollars
from you right yeah yeah but people who
get pell grants like myself are people
who fall within a household income range
and they say well based on where you're
going you know or based on the tuition
that you're trying to
pay for
you qualify
for additional aid
from the government that's given to you
right yeah that's good now now here's
the thing about pell grants and i want
to point out um because i think this is
an important conversation because a lot
on the left are saying oh all or nothing
you bastard which actually i have a big
problem with that right but if you look
at this plan if you look at this plan
joe biden is actually extending more
money to folks who need it more if you
look at it so he is giving more than
just ten thousand dollars here's why
pell grants like gabe said if you
graduate college and your parents don't
have a high
high um household income you can apply
for pell grants if you fall within that
that category of pell grants the
government helps you out and actually
they provide you a college education
that is and they use pell grants as an
avenue to pay for your college but i
think a lot of people forget about also
where pell grants are used and why this
is so [ __ ]
important most people who go back to
college okay after they may have went to
college dropped out or they went to high
school they didn't go to college and
they tried to have a career and they go
back to college when they have a family
this is super important
because pell grants also are given to
people who go back to college who are
adults they're not their parents aren't
helping it's called they have children
continuing education right they have and
so they're trying to advance their their
their economic mobility now what biden
is doing is he's rewarding not just the
folks who can't afford college when
they're coming in high school with this
he's also
giving those folks more leeway on this
debt forgiveness if they went to college
with the pell grant while they were
working and had a family even because a
lot of those pell grant recipients are
that exactly so
um again there's a little more details
on little a little more nuance in this
plan but the majority of folks in this
country who still have student debt will
either have
the entirety of it wiped out or they
will have up to 10 to 20 depending on
your situation
right given to you for student debt the
the thing about this plan is this is
almost exactly what he said he was going
to do well yeah i mean
people need to remember that because
during the campaign trail he was asked
there were there are two moments on
camera that people need to remember
there was a woman who asked during the
campaign trail said will you forgive up
to 50 000 alone in in student debt and
student loan debt right and he said nope
i won't do that
because
i don't want to reward especially
because it was the answer was around i
don't want to specifically reward
the people who decided to go to these
ivy league schools you know or they have
the ability to pay for these loans or
what have you
i also think that people who go to
community college it should be free
right it should be [ __ ] free which is
anybody who wants an idea
a lot of states have that capability
they do it inside the state
but the federal government is not right
exactly and so these are things like
yeah it would be great if all you know
if we if everything was was created
equal and places were free of charge
right the
you know as if we lived in another
country you know going to university it
would be covered right by the government
however we live in america where we have
to um live under a capitalistic
structure and the only way to do things
is to pay for them um especially when
higher the cost of higher education
is
astoundingly greater than the rate that
inflation grows and i used to work for a
higher education company
and i would work with colleges um and
and trying to help students kind of
integrate into school especially as they
were transferring out of a community
college transferring into or going into
a community college and trying to feel
like they actually belonged right
outside of the fact of like the
financial side but the biggest problem i
have with people who are saying all or
nothing like these busters right they're
like it's got to be all forgiven or
nothing look i'm the i'm a person who
had a lot of [ __ ] loans and i had a
significant amount of pell grants like i
had you know my parents took out
personal loans for college right
and there was a point at which i was at
a position where i was like look i could
empty the bank and start from scratch
and kind of because i i refinanced my
loans twice tony to get this even lower
right and and through through private i
mean to get that like the interest rates
lower right yeah to go from you know
variables just to a four to go right
yeah exactly so i had variable fixed
interest rates i had to refinance them
to get lower i had to refinance them
again which means i was extending
the loan payout period right and at a
certain point i got i was fortunate
enough where i was able to pay off the
loans but i look at the right i look at
the situation right now where people say
uh we
want all or nothing and i think that's a
very
not like naive way to look at it and and
because you would benefit more from all
right right yeah i would have totally
benefited from all i would you know i
would have benefited from if it was just
five thousand dollars right the the
impact that that can make which means
like less money is taken out of my
paycheck that i have to pay every month
on top of all the other things car rent
food whatever it might be in terms of
expenditures
i look at that and i say
even a little bit of assistance would
have helped me out during that time
um you know there were times when i
you know i was eating [ __ ] oatmeal
for literally oatmeal for three meals a
day oatmeal is good
well i know that but it's like oh like
like you were on oatmeal ramen noodle
because yeah i mean
oatmeal and peanut butter literally my
meal for a couple years was almost two
to three meals a like a day was that
type of thing because i was like i gotta
i need to save as much money i'm not
making a lot of money i need to pay off
these loans especially ones who had
higher interest rates or ones that were
variable i was like i got to get i got
to [ __ ] pay for this
so when i hear people say it's all or
nothing
i think it's very ignorant yeah it would
be great if we had [ __ ] all loans
you're talking about like nina turner
because nina turner yeah yeah
yes nina turner says it's got to be all
or nothing and this is more of the young
turks tyt stuff where it's all or
nothing type [ __ ] democrats are failing
because they're not delivering all which
is [ __ ] ridiculous and the way that i
look at it right now is someone who
received pell grants who had to pay my
own loans who has to deal with other
personal loans like anyone else in this
country right if i was able to get
that type of assistance at the time that
would have been amazing but i'm also not
one of these people now who says well i
should be credited for paying off my
loans [ __ ] that if we look at any
generation before us every generation
always works to better the one that
follows it right right you should work
to follow the one that follows exactly
well here here's let me give you one
generation well let me give you a
perspective because i had several
student loans now i'm a two-time college
dropout right i'm i'm a [ __ ] loser as
far as most happy barkins and i think
some people would define me as that you
can write it in the comments section if
you'd like now
and really in any thread you'd like you
can go type that out and i will be
highly offended but here's what i here's
what i'll tell you gabe is that i had
student loans and i paid them off i
guess it was about um
you know about four or five years ago
maybe six years ago i had several
thousand dollars a student debt um it
continued and i i i worked hard i got
um i saved up enough money that i could
pay him off and i just said you know
what i'm i'm not gonna wait on anyone to
give me relief i'm just gonna pay him
off i made the decision now today i
could be really pissed off about that
right because in today's world
the federal government would actually
relieve me of whatever debt i had left
and i'd be cool i'd be clean but i'm not
pissed off about it i'm not mad about it
because i made those decisions i did
those things i feel like i feel like
anyone in our country who has their
degree who's benefited in this country
from our democracy
and and like you said each generation
getting better and better i think they
want what they should want what is best
for the next generation and the
generation after that and i think in
this moment because more than the 10
grand or the 20 grand whichever whatever
amount you're actually going to receive
here i think what is most important for
everyone to carry around
in your pocket as a pro-democracy person
as you're messaging out there
is that this american president did this
in a time where he could have looked at
the american people said i know i
promised that i would give you
ten thousand dollars for your student
debt but that's during that was during a
pandemic when everyone was doing bad
right when when unemployment was almost
30 percent times have changed and now we
have to reevaluate right we have record
and record record low unemployment
everyone is employed in the country they
can afford to pay their own i can't let
the federal government put the bill for
you he could have done he certainly
could have done that he did not do that
he delivered on his promise to the
american people and and here's one thing
that i'll say about dark brandon
if i'll say anything
he actually gets up in the morning puts
his [ __ ] shoes on and understands
that that office that he holds is the
american people's office
he is the president of the american
people and he is going to do his
damnedess regardless if he's successful
or not regardless if he goes as far as
some liberals want him or not regardless
if he goes further than what
conservatives want him or not to do i
think he really truly does have that
empathy the decency to have the american
working class and the majority of
american people in mind when he's trying
to make these decisions that affect our
country and affect our democracy i mean
you could argue a lot on foreign policy
and national security and some of the
other social issues but this one
specifically
this one specifically what he is going
to do when he comes out here in about an
hour and talks about it
he is going to give
people a chance to get one more leg up
in this country and in this economy than
they had yesterday
and and he's going to do that in a time
where he's continued to try to give legs
up i mean we just watched them pass the
inflation reduction act which is going
to give a ton of people leg up in health
care it's going to give a climate and
energy a leg up he gave the covet relief
package which is giving p which gave
people a leg up which he tried to
deliver the the the bbb bill which would
have continued the child tax credit he
delivered infrastructure gabe you
delivered infrastructure with which
which trump said would happen two weeks
two weeks from now two weeks from now
right he delivered that package to the
american people the chips act he's
delivering these things to the american
people right and that i think is most
important when we have the contrast
today because i want to show you the
contrast this is hilarious this is peter
navarro
this is him talking about if trump
becomes president again who the [ __ ] is
going to be empowered now let me ask you
let's watch this video but the question
i have for you after we get done with
this video is do you [ __ ] think any
of these [ __ ] he says in this
video would have any inclination to even
consider the american people when it
comes to college debt let's listen
cash patel
nope great guy mike flynn no part of the
administration we bring bob lighthizer
back nope because he did a good job as
as the trade
a guy um you know the attorney general
which is really a key spot
kind of fun to have judge jeanine there
nope nope nope
do not have the budget for wine even
this guy even this guy on this trader
news network laughs like box wine box
host box wine that's what who the [ __ ]
you want in charge of the justice
department you [ __ ] nuts
she wouldn't even be able to find your
own shoes get the [ __ ] out of here let's
continue
the uh bill barr was a total total
mistake yeah
totally agree totally angry just bad but
the guy before him i mean i loved that
guy before him no but he just
was he fell prey to the deep state
inside stage
he's gone so i lay that all out if
people can look at the dream cabinet in
in the book the dream cabinet that
sounds like a nightmare cabinet can you
can you imagine i i mean it goes on and
on here
is it here this is uh
but here's the thing this is the
contrast folks the contrast today in
this moment in history the thing that
you should really reflect on today
is the american president that the
majority of people beyond any other
majority had ever voted for
voted for him because he was
decent that was the bar gabe he was
decent that was the bar that was really
like yeah look i may not agree on
certain policies but he's a he's he's a
better person right he's at least he's
got decency but today we are seeing the
contrast of of peter navarro laying out
this absolute [ __ ] slog of fascist a
fascist state that would rip apart
american families would rip apart
american people would absolutely
ostracize every single every single
person who was even on the fringe of
what they consider social and social
justice and the social issues that they
want to make a culture war in this
country
and the contrast is that guy is in court
this well he was his
motion that he filed him and his his
fake persona appears uh filed in this
court in florida she's like this thing's
written in crown and this is the wrong
court this is the wrong the other which
i i haven't gotten an answer on this i i
asked ben
uh from from the midas touch brothers uh
to give me an answer from just a lawyer
perspective because what i was curious
about is basically the way that i read
that was that the judge said
this is what you did not answer this
basically this is what you did wrong
resubmit it
the right way
now
i don't know if that's normal procedure
for a judge to say
uh
fix these mistakes and come back or if a
judge normally says
uh this is dog [ __ ] i'm throwing it out
so i don't know if that's a typical kind
of uh way to go about it but
uh that's the way that i read it she was
basically like all right uh here are
some mistakes fix those and bring it
back like you had them like a legal
like a teacher yeah
looks at it and she's like oh okay
i'm gonna have to grade you on a curve
here yeah she's like you might want to
focus on question three
maybe go back to your desk think about
it and then come back you still have 15
minutes before the end of the end of the
class right like
that is that is the way that i
interpreted it as opposed to like if i
was a judge and again i don't know if
this is what the judge is supposed to do
or not but if i was i'd look at the [ __ ]
and be like this is dog [ __ ] uh you got
nothing right here and then i would go
[ __ ] toss it out but again i don't
know if that's the right well i mean the
winner is he's trying he's trying to
shop a criminal court which is not how
it works all you can shop a civil court
that is absolutely how it works and he's
done that time and time again but he has
never he's never been in a situation
where he doesn't know he can't shop
a criminal court speaking speaking of
crimes against humanity these two holy
[ __ ] you see laura loomer here and nick
fuentes i don't i don't know what the
hell they're making a drink what is that
i don't know this is this is before
um the announcement of the actual
election let's let's watch these these
two lunatics um which is kind of funny
it's kind of weird to have a holocaust
denier and someone who hates muslims
because
muslims hate jews
is the talk the bigotry party right but
but they're but they're clinging glasses
here that they're gonna tear down
american democracy i'm not [ __ ] you
they almost say as much listen to this
is it pepsi is that what i'm pouring
into you know what did they did somebody
make a drink like and when i say that
what i mean is like did somebody create
some sort of energy drink or coffee
drink or something like that like like a
patriot energy drink drinkers yeah like
uh you know yeah it's like uh you know
manga fuel or some [ __ ] something like
that right fascist fuel is what it might
be that's it fascist fuel hey i'm not
saying we shouldn't uh write that down
write that down yeah
okay so let's let's watch them clink the
glasses of fascist fuel together
absolutely
to the hostile takeover of the
republican party
we're going to tear down american
democracy
cheers with pepsi nitro i know that's a
horrible that's a horrible commercial
for pepsi nature they might want to they
might want to get on that and
put a stop to that nonsense but i'm just
saying that is
uh
interesting weird it's weird now here's
i it gets oh it gets so much better here
this is this is fantastic and you're
going to love this and i love this
little clip that
comes after this it's the same night
it's just a little later in the night
last night
after
she clinked the glass with the america
first nazi leader is she crying
oh she's crying and it's not tears of
happiness
it's not a tears of sadness
listen this is one of this this makes me
feel all warm and fuzzy inside i just
love
better than pepsi nitro i love some maca
tears let's listen
we are losing our country because of big
tech election interference
please start taking this issue seriously
please
because the american people deserve
representation and that's
that's why i'm here for congress
it's why i ran for congress in 2022
why i'm going to keep fighting
[Applause]
shut the [ __ ] up
oh my god nothing nothing gets me
laughing more than than laura loomer
crying in her little her little fascist
laura laura loomer [ __ ] bonehead is a
crazy q anon wannabe fascist dictator
who is clearly a very sensitive
snowflake who was unable to take a loss
and had to cry
about it these are the same people that
said
oh hey get over it move on
don't [ __ ] cry right he crying out
you [ __ ] [ __ ] macho right
these god damn people
so someone like laura loomer who's this
crazy q on nut job who wanted to put
those type of ideals
and and uh ideologies
into our democracy [ __ ] no so i'm glad
i'm glad that she lost i'm glad that
she's crying i i hope she continues to
do this i hope she continues to do this
she continues to lose and she continues
to cry over over [ __ ] and she's also the
one who said she was the most canceled
person in the world right yeah well i
mean her book she you can read it in her
book on amazon and right and and and
ebay and everywhere that you can
actually buy books right right and we
were playing we played the clip of
walter interviewing her right and was
like so what's going on with your books
oh i'm the most cancelled person in the
world and she's like oh okay well can
you can you get your book anywhere she's
like well
every week booking everywhere well i
mean yeah you can get it on amazon
you're not canceled you're playing the
victim you lost
don't cry
that's how it goes uh laura laura is it
laura laurie i don't know
no i don't know but anyways here's laura
q q bloomer bloomer
q loomer
q loomer keep running it's i i would
love to watch i i would wait every two
years for this content i literally would
wait every two years for that content
speaking of content and crybabies rona
mcdaniel the gop chair
she's crying that joe biden's gonna
gonna gonna do this student doe
student debt relief she even quotes a
really bogus ass poll again polls are
[ __ ] we've seen this and you can't
believe any of these [ __ ]
59 of americans say that if biden bails
out student loan debt inflation will get
even worse
okay number one
that is nonsense that inflation is going
to get worse
if if 59 59
or if americans get ten thousand dollars
stuffed in their pocket you're a dumb
[ __ ] you're so stupid
number number number two who in the [ __ ]
do you think why did why do we would we
listen to americans who are experts on
the american economy when it comes to
inflation probably
and then this poll that says 59
no get the [ __ ] out of here because if
this poll is of course this was my
response
[Laughter]
[Music]
this was my response here i actually i
ain't quote tweeter i don't give a [ __ ]
um i said what is that from
uh uh multiplicity
good oh yeah
it's one of the best michael keaton
movies of all time it's [ __ ]
hilarious it's gotta be batman oh dude
it's it's great it's great
it's great um
but the uh i i wrote other than this um
uh jerk off uh um gif i said 59 of
americans don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ]
then if this poll is true if this really
is true that 59 of america i don't think
it's true i think it's all [ __ ] so
what i i'm looking at this poll right
now it's a cnbc poll right and it does
say 59 of americans worry student loan
forgiveness will make inflation worse
now if you break this down you see that
81
of republicans are especially concerned
that it'll make it worse which is nearly
double democrats are at 41
but i think the other thing to remember
too is that people need to understand
how
injecting
money like this isn't this isn't
injecting artificial money and by that i
mean like no one's getting a stimulus
check here right right money that we say
oh we're printing more money it's money
that they would spend on something else
this is money
that you have already earned we've
already been paid
this is just money you don't have to pay
which is different than money is saying
like hey here's an extra check for just
being
in our country right instead of be given
ten thousand dollars you're going to
save right you will see that
it's like a coupon exactly which means
that you might say hey instead of paying
the 10 000 over this period of time for
this loan i will now use that money to
either put into savings maybe get
interest rate maybe i will go buy
a new tv or i'll go buy an appliance
that i need for my house because now
i have been relieved of this ten
thousand dollars right it's not i'm not
giving someone ten thousand dollars i'm
saying we are reducing your loan
by ten thousand dollars or twenty
thousand dollars
to allow you to have more assistance
that you can use elsewhere right right
well and you can buy goods services
which is only going to increase the
right it's going to pump money back into
i will go buy something i will go go
shop local i will inhibit in my
community my business here's also the
thing is that your tax the same on this
money because it's money that you earn
like you said your tax the same on this
money rather you spend it to give it to
the federal government because that's
literally who you're giving it to it's
the federal government because every
single student loan is a federally
backed loan now whether it's a pell
grant or otherwise they're all federally
backed
pretty much um but if you if that you're
giving it anyways why not spend it into
the economy and really there should be
no one more excited about this about
what joe biden's doing then donald trump
gave and spare with me on this bear with
me okay i think i know where you're
going with this but sure yeah he is have
you seen this they're holding
uh a a dinner for him it's a it's a
fundraising dinner it's a it's a hundred
thousand dollars per person i'm not
[ __ ] you what
a hundred look at private dinner and
photo opportunity with former president
donald j trump a hundred thousand
dollars
the manga again against the make america
agree again again again and again and
again and again and again um
pam bondi of all people that [ __ ]
criminal uh you know she was the
criminal down in florida uh who made the
trump university uh lawsuit go away and
then uh we have rick grinnell oh my god
and matt whitaker morgan national
finance chairman kimberly gilfoy a
person who's gonna steal your hundred
thousand dollars um when you actually
give it to this cause that's who's gonna
steal it from you is coming i don't know
sounds like the best is yet to come on
but here's here's the thing is this
there should be no more people excited
that some of these people are going to
get 10 or 20 grand
i bet i bet there's already emails going
out like hey that money you're gonna
save on student loans don't send it to
anyone yet
make sure to give it to the
buy a trump car a trump debt student
loan card
good platinum student loan card i
i i mean you act like that's
unreasonable there's it's not crazy i
was no while you were talking i was just
checking my uh actually if i had gotten
one yet
where you're gonna send your student
debt money right yeah yeah
uh no the last text i got from them was
about um the uh voter canvassing record
and they wanted me to join their their
database their listserv oh well did you
uh did you enter your name into their um
yeah i said [ __ ] around and find out at
gmail.com
my name is go [ __ ] yourself middle name
[ __ ]
last name yourself oh boy so yeah i
can't wait to get that that email
speaking of telling people to go [ __ ]
themselves here is a report from cnn
about um new york's 19th and how we have
this row rage let's listen people can
see curious pre-dobs over this which is
the overturning of roe versus wade on
average democrats were wanting six
points worse
than joshua in special elections these
are elections that actually have results
uh you know people take seats and in the
fourth special election since dobbs
they're running five points
better that's an 11 point swing if you
believe this poll which again i i'm
inclined not to believe these polls that
these numbers are way the [ __ ] off
they're they're antiquated but this goes
to show you of that of the um what's his
name is it pat ryan
i want to say pat ryan he wanted to say
paul ryan
because it's p and ryan don't get
anywhere near paul ryan
it's pat ryan let me let me pull that up
here yeah here's uh midas touch had this
on instagram after he won here's here's
pat ryan here he wins new york's 19th
special election now this is significant
because it wasn't a primary last night
this was a special election um this was
for that seat specifically
um
because they had a vacancy but but this
uh pat ryan won
handily when he was supposed to lose by
10 and biden only won this by two points
so i think the row rage
is there
um the row rage is certainly there and i
think that it's going to continue to be
there and it's going to continue to to
scare the bejesus out of these son of a
[ __ ] um speaking scaring the bejesus
out of someone
uh donald trump was confused about the
election last night oh was he doesn't
surprise me here's here's it let me pull
it up here's his statement look at this
he said looks like a fantastic evening
of all wins great candidates oh look
he's congratulating all the democratic
candidates too well you know what's
funny is he
it feels like to me he doesn't
understand what a primary he's like yay
all republicans all won their races yeah
what the [ __ ] are you talking about man
like i said of course i've been calling
him dude here lately dude dude's excited
about republicans winning republican
primaries like he is he's elated that
republicans can win the republican
primaries dude
man i don't know i mean the guy
the guy is uh
i don't think he's 100 with it these
days you know i think the paranoia and
you think his focus is on something else
he thinks yeah yeah his focus is uh
is is improperly filing court documents
to sue the whole us government because
he is unfairly treated because he stole
documents that he said were his but
we're really the governments and because
he stole them he's now in trouble but he
feels like he shouldn't be in trouble
and that he's the victim and that it was
unfairly unfair treatment on him by
merrick garland christopher wray who he
appointed and uh and and dark brandon
you know so
right well that happens that happens
when when you when you have these things
here's another victim and uh the victim
crying victim for the other victims
these people they they really they
[ __ ] doubled and now tripling oh my
god and it's even worse it's even worse
now that we found out that their actual
top secret documents like top secret
[ __ ] yeah this is [ __ ] that what they're
confirming more this morning that these
documents are not supposed to be outside
of skiff like these things can threaten
our nationalists i just want to know
because here's the thing we were talking
about yesterday and one point that i
wanted to bring up was
he has these documents not should not
have these documents at all no one
should have these documents outside of
these these locations right i want to
know who helped this [ __ ] take
those things out
yeah because you know he didn't carry
those [ __ ] bucks right right like if
you're if you're transporting from one
location the next like there was a
handoff that happened where certain
documents did not get transferred or
photos were taken of documents in in
transfer like i don't know how they got
out of the hands they were supposed to
get in and nobody checked for it
but
i have a feeling that there is more than
one person at hand that helped him out
here so
multiple people cash patel
and that's just one well i mean he's all
him but admitted it
well yeah he admitted that he was like i
was in the room it was december and
january when he was waving the [ __ ]
sharpie and he's classifying everything
right but also it's not just him i want
to know who else this is a coordinated
effort to get several
hundreds of of documents pages of
documents that were classified top
secret skiff sci documents that he
should not have had his hands on outside
of those who were supposed to protect
and guard them so i want to know who the
[ __ ]
gave those to him do you think and i
want to know right now tony do you think
he took like his happy meal inside this
gift like his little happy meal box
no because they because they get
he ate the cheeseburger
out of his happy meal and then he's like
when he he just stuck the classified
document on the wrapper and he's like
wadding it up and sticks
no i'm gonna throw this away outside the
skiff
i just had this very crazy i i have an
idea for a sketch now and it's all it's
a document mule i document me oh my god
2 000 meals i bet you can make i bet you
can make a movie about this i could and
probably call call it 2 000 pound mule
um or something like that basically it's
a it would be about a guy who's like oh
yeah like there are drug mules out there
but like i'm a doctor you know like i i
ingest how many how many documents do
you think donald trump can keester how
do you know do you think they're like
watching them in the skiff and like sir
what are you sticking up your
think no keys
pay no attention
they're like why did you why did you
fold the paper the long way
well you know
to uh to make sure it fits
it's got to be a certain size right yeah
fitting up your
lindsey graham here uh let's see what he
said on fox and friends the material
they say boxes of over 100 documents
classifications marking over 700 pages
do you not believe those numbers
i want to i did you know i read about
the mueller that that's a yes that's
that's a yes yes yes yes this is you
this is you
attempt i have not even seen this clip
but i i'm going to assume that lindsey
graham attempts at what about ism right
now to go off into something he
mentioned mueller so i guess he's gonna
say that there's something about mueller
he's gonna do a what about his and by
not answering the question and be like
oh well these other documents [ __ ] that
no he he knows he's in the wrong and
he's trying to figure out how not to say
yes it was wrong or yes he shouldn't
have had these documents
well i mean lindsay does a lot of things
that he lies about i mean he's like a
walking a walking lie but here's the
thing
is lindsey graham absolutely believes
what the the government is saying here
he knows it's the [ __ ] truth he was a
goddamn prosecutor in the military for
crying out he's a jag lawyer give me a
[ __ ] break this guy knows the law he
knows how it works he knows what's gonna
happen here that's why he's sweating so
hard on fox and prince because he's
about to
feel of uh the the uh find out phase of
the [ __ ] around saga down in georgia
he's about to get his ass spanked over
that um who knows if there'll be
criminal charges brought against lindsay
it looks like there are going to be
because he wouldn't be working so hard
not to go down and actually
give his testimony of what happened if
he wasn't scared of criminal prosecution
uh to try to stall this effort but here
because we we
the mueller report is now in the news
here recently too and i don't want to
breeze over that where billboard lied
billboard like there was obstruction
there was collusion who woulda thunk it
who would have thunk it that and we're
not gonna we're not going to be able to
see right what it was right and that's
why lindsey graham is projecting here
obviously lindsey graham knows that
there's obstruction and collusion in the
report that's what's going to come out
they're trying to get ahead of that he's
also trying to get ahead of his
prosecution in georgia he's also trying
to get ahead of the idea that the bites
are the president of the united states
stole top secret documents illegally
held them illegally when they asked for
him back he illegally told them no go
[ __ ] yourself and then when he said i
gave him back he illegally kept more of
them
and he's going to be indicted on these
charges more than likely it is going to
be very hard for anyone to look away
from this but let's watch mr look away
here
describe it investigation every week
right in the new york times in
washington post nobody told me that they
uh altered information to the fisa court
nobody told me that they they had
information that the entire basis for
the carter page warrant was uh was a
bunch of here saying bar talk so no i
don't trust these people what i want to
do is see the affidavit this is a raid
on the former president of the united
states no personal he wasn't arrested 80
days before an election and you're
supposed to let me i'm supposed to trust
the new york times and the washington
post hell
so here's lindsey graham not trusting
not trusting the reporting which has
always pretty much turned out to be
exactly what they reported um even if it
was if they're complaining and worried
about something you can mostly uh assume
that it's it's real and it's absolutely
absolutely again and lindsey graham is a
perfect example
of why donald trump is not going to have
a fun time here with these classified uh
document charges um it is more
and more that we find out because again
it's we said yesterday it's like every
few hours that we find out something new
about it right he believes that there
are his documents and that he deserves
them despite them being the property of
the united states of america right
despite the fact that he went
cherry-picking through the documents
before handing over what the final set
was the last round right right like this
is a guy that is a threat to our
democracy he is a threat to our country
and the republican party have decided to
triple quadruple
down
on this idea that trump was allowed and
was totally capable and justified in
taking these documents away from the
government specifically
top secret classified documents that
would threaten our own security and they
have established that their position
is look
we are so far down the [ __ ] rabbit
hole with this [ __ ] that we now
need to follow him to the end
of the earth right to the end down into
[ __ ]
uh you know
wonderland because that's where they're
going right now soon they're gonna be
you got the [ __ ] mad hatter and all
these [ __ ] down there and
they're like yep cool these guys are
like us that's how [ __ ] crazy it is
they're going down this rabbit hole and
following him no questions asked
just doubling and you know tripling
quadrupling down i mean jesus they're
even saying like mar-a-lago has secured
this nonsense that the security here's a
report and you pointed it out almost
immediately on twitter
about the chinese national that they had
to arrest who broke into mar-a-lago
here's a report i think it's on uh
joy reid's show let's listen there is
the chinese businesswoman by the name of
yujin zhang back in 2019 she trespassed
at mar-a-lago initially making it past
secret service agents at a security
checkpoint eventually she was detained
and found to be carrying four cell
phones a laptop computer a hard drive
and a thumb drive that may have included
some form of malware
and apparently back in her hotel room
she had a device that detects hidden
cameras and more than eight thousand
dollars in cash as prosecutors filed
secret evidence under seal
saying it had national security
implications but but but gabe
mar-a-lago is one of the most secure
locations on earth no one has access to
these documents well right one could
have just opened this door or just like
or went to the blue house or yeah jammed
open this padlock
the extra pad laundry basket out of
melania's clothes well you know texas
paul brought up a really good point that
i think yesterday that i think maybe uh
should be a consideration and i actually
think there's more than one informant
here but he brought up that it possibly
could be secret service that is the
informant here that it's like we
they are their job is to protect him but
they also have an oath to the
constitution right and they're watching
as he's damaging i mean it just takes
one person man one because they can see
something and say something you know i
mean
against enemies foreign
so
i think that's something to consider um
when you're talking about who the who
the actual informant is
um when you're talking about this
this uh documents um thing i i want to
give the audience an idea we're going to
go to
um the
press conference
of the president of the united states
he's going to deliver remarks it looks
like the bottom of the hour so stay with
us right here we normally go away in in
five minutes
i think we're gonna go three hours today
we're gonna go three hours so i want to
be clear on this what's going to happen
you can stay right here you can go to
the midas touch youtube channel as well
if you're on twitter i'm going to turn
twitter off so you can move to
uh youtube just come over to the tony
michaels podcast you can join us live
now so subscribe while you're there you
can also go to the midas touch youtube
channel gabe where you should subscribe
there as well on the midas touch network
as well now we're also going to be
putting this up on all the directories
so apple spotify google they'll all be
there um you can also follow us on
twitter again i'm gonna take it down off
of twitter um the broadcast as we get to
closer to the top of the hour here we'll
go to a commercial break when we come
back from that commercial break we will
then start our coverage
of the press conference so don't go
anywhere sit tight if you want to watch
this press conference of the president
united states um go through this stuff
in about three minutes we'll go to a
commercial break and we'll do that gabe
i'm excited some
when we're talking about announcements
and news i'm and speaking of the mind as
touch network i'm excited about this
week do you know what's going to happen
on friday this week we do bone end of
the week every single week tomorrow that
we put the poll out yep the audience can
go on youtube or twitter and they can
they can vote there at toni michael's
pod or here on the youtube channel for
the bone end of the week because you the
audience votes you decide we believe in
democracy that's right that's right well
we want to practice every week voting
right yeah yeah we want to practice we
want to get good practice on engaging in
the ballot but every friday we break
down your vote of bonehead of the week
on the second hour now this week
it's going to be a little different it's
going to be a little different this week
because this week and we're not sure
what time yet um but on friday evening
bonus of the week will appear on the
midas touch youtube channel we will
broadcast that's right we will be
broadcasting the replay of bone end of
the week on the midas touch youtube
channel
um so make sure to go over and follow
the minus touch network so to make sure
that you um re-watch or if you miss it
you can replay the bonut of the week
uh every single friday evening again i'm
not sure exactly what time i don't think
we have a time um no i don't know stone
yet but i we're gonna work towards there
the next couple days to get um the
bonehead of the week time secured and
let you guys know exactly what time that
is but make sure to vote tomorrow
you and your [ __ ] little hands
listening for anyone listening you know
you got to come over and watch it but i
am silently clapping with my many hands
here your mini hands many a little mini
applause
i got to do a few things here a few
business items here um while while we go
to commercial break i gotta i gotta send
a link here to the um maybe i'll
describe what i'm doing this is yeah do
it to tell the show
live how we uh do it live do it live do
it live because you know that we are the
kings
of live broadcast here we are on the
money network okay here's that link so
we got that going um let's do this let's
go to a break again i know we normally
end at this time but stick around don't
go anywhere don't do not turn off this
video
if you want to watch the the press
conference of the president united
states delivering remarks about the
student loan relief
stick right here we're going to be
simulcasting i think we're going to have
uh possibly some the mizellas brothers
uh no i don't i don't need one nope okay
uh it'll just it'll transfer over and i
just gotta reset it during the
commercial so there may be a little
a little production glitch here but we
will get there i promise i promise so
stick around don't go anywhere if you
want to listen to the presidential
remarks i think we're going to have the
midas touch brothers with us here don't
go in there stay right here stay right
here don't go anywhere right here in the
chat stay right down
go anywhere
we will be right back right after these
messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
dears tammy by the time we reach dc we
was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[Music]
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome and back
we switched over to the touch network
here
we are on the minus touch network if
you're joining us uh let's turn let's
turn twitter off here
i think i can get rid of that thing
maybe maybe not i don't know
oh my gosh
i'll red there we go there we go
i'm just trying to there we go okay
there we go okay so we're off twitter
we're on the midas touch network
uh here on the mind of touch youtube
channel thanks for joining us if you're
just tuning in
we have some coverage that we want to
share with you here on the midas touch
network um gabe can you copy that link
and send it over
to them so they have that link so they
can start spreading that around the
interwebs the the youtube link can you
do that for me yes i can on the midas
touch yeah put that put that over there
so they have that that link um we are
going to be holding the remarks from the
president of the united states joe biden
about
the
uh student debt relief program that he
is going to release today uh it sounds
like that they're going to be delivering
the marks at the bottom of the hour i'm
not sure
exactly how long those remarks are going
to be we'll probably stick around
through this hour we're going to have
commentary coming in me and gabe are
going to provide commentary as best we
can we also
are going to be joined i think by the
midas touch the mizellas brothers
possibly ben possibly brett i don't know
if jordy's feeling well enough to uh to
join us but they're going to be joining
us here on the midas touch network
welcome welcome welcome everyone to our
special coverage
of the remarks uh for for joe biden
uh president joe biden
and as he
as he's going to
uh give remarks about the student debt
relief
today um i am tony michaels this is my
co-host and executive producer gabe
sanchez hello so we're live here on the
midas touch network excuse me we had to
do this on the fly yeah when you do live
things like live streaming and stuff you
kind of got to do it on the fly so we're
trying to put it together here um yeah
there's he's asking about uh he wants
can you can you make him a thumbnail to
get it up there yeah well after you told
me no you don't need well i i mean it's
gonna put one up is what i meant yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna put one up i'll
switch it to house but i mean but i mean
it it kind of goes with what's happening
i don't know it says brandon cancels
debt so i mean that's you know yeah well
i gotta change it which means it changes
it for everything right
no no no just just send it over here
i'll i'll change it i can do it on my
end yeah yeah yeah but it's the same
broadcast the one from this morning
no
right but no but if you change it just
on that channel
just at the top just on that youtube
it'll change it there
only change it there you just go to edit
and that'll change but don't turn it off
because then oh man then we'll lose that
yeah don't screw it up gabe or you can
send it over yeah i'll just send you
the suits send it to the suit so yeah
they'll take care of it over there so um
but if they if they want to send that
link around i'm going to get um again
see we're all on the fly here and and if
anyone knows we actually host the show
and we actually
um we're producing the show as we're
going so if it seems like we're working
and talking at the same time that's
exactly what we're doing
so let's let's put that there add banner
let's see
there we go see there we go live present
announced historic student loan relief
here on the midas touch network thank
you for joining us thanks for everyone
sticking around uh for the live coverage
of president biden delivering remarks on
the student
loan relief program that is historic i i
want i want to tell everyone who's
joining us
that uh i brought up this this morning
that there is going to be a very stark
contrast a very stark contrast today
between
in our history the president united
states joe biden is going to come out
and he's going to deliver a promise to
the american working class he's going to
make sure
and then that they actually
have debt relief in the form of their
student debt relief i believe that's
very important and it's contrasted by
the former guy
down in florida who gets basically he
gets rejected by a federal judge because
he kind of wrote this order half-ass
himself he's representing himself pretty
much and also he filed it with the wrong
court she knows
she knows he found it with the wrong
court and that is the contrast here
you have a president of a party who is
pro-democracy who is delivering for the
american people just as he promised he
would do
um it's not really that far off from
what he said he would do on the campaign
trail gabe it's not even that far no i
mean it is exactly what he said he said
he would do ten thousand he would also
like to say you it will also like
community colleges to be free for people
to attend you know he never promised a
50k he said when he answered the
question no i will not uh i will not
forgive 50k
um so people need to understand kind of
where those things lay out but he did
make a promise during the campaign trail
for 10k
and he did that and went beyond that for
those who have pell grants and went up
to twenty thousand dollars so he
delivered on his promise and added more
to what was done
right
um kim i'm gonna sell let's see i think
we should pull the
let's see here let me share my screen i
want to pull that graphic up of what
you're talking about there
um of because i i think that is getting
a little confused uh some people are
getting confused about what
what is actually uh happening with this
program this is actually the white
house's copy of their document this
morning that they're putting out for
this program uh for giving the debt 20
000 if you went to college on pell
grants and then 10 000 if you didn't
receive pell grants
um
just okay he's got he's going there so
i'm going to see if they're going to
join us but
gabe now you have personally personally
you're going to see some of the benefits
from this so tell us i'm not oh you had
you're not going no no no i'm not going
to well here so for full context like
i am uh or i was the recipient of pell
grants okay i was in school i received
pell grants because my family did not
make enough money
um
you know we well actually the way where
our household income was we were
eligible for the recipient of a pell
grant or repel grants
uh i over time have paid those off
um
and i wish
uh i wish i was i wish i would have been
on the receiving end however i'm not and
i am super grateful
and i am super happy for those right now
who are able to receive those benefits
of getting 10 to 20 000
removed from their loans and being
forgiven
um
it is something that i feel like it is a
rising tide that will lift all boats in
this scenario it is something it's not
injecting money into the economy it is
it is it is cutting costs for those
people who need it right now right you
know we we talked about it on the show
earlier today which is 59 percent of
americans which is 81 of republicans
believe that this will cause an increase
in inflation which that is not the case
here right just the understanding in the
fundamental economics economy
fundamental
of economics in our country right now is
reducing and cutting the costs
of
of
the the loans that you took out as a
student will not add to the inflation
problem right we are saving money that
will allow people to spend it on car
payments their rent their mortgage
food their children like these are
things that will help go into the
economy and actually boost
what's what we have going on so i as a
recipient of pell grants super grateful
for getting them
uh and and i am super happy and grateful
for those who are receiving the benefits
of those cost reductions
when it comes to their own because
that's what it is that's what it is it's
not a payment it's a cost right right of
that call and the people that say oh i
want a credit for the things that i paid
off i say no no no no no no no you paid
it off yes
it was hard work and you did it and i
did it as well
but
again we should be hoping for the best
for those within our own generation and
those generations that are before and
after us
and what i mean by that is i say that
those people
we should be hoping that we make it
easier for them to attend college
to pay off their loans to make it easier
to to continue education right and so
when i say that right now i'm just i i'm
i'm very happy because again we talked
on our show earlier today biden didn't
need to do this right the economy is
doing well he didn't have to say oh well
you know what
er you don't really need it right now
right this is we have record low
unemployment
you guys got jobs you can afford your
student loans pull yourself up by your
bootstraps type stuff right right and i
personally had to refinance my student
loans twice in order to pay them off
and so it wasn't an easy thing at all
and i don't wish that on anyone right
because
the price of the cost of tuition has has
increased exponentially over the the uh
the inflation rate that we have right
it's something that is just insane
especially for private institutions
and the cost of attending versus what
you're getting on on the receiving end
as a result of your education
and so
this is something that will greatly
benefit not only the people who are
getting those cost reductions by getting
10 to 20k forgiven but also the people
that will then will receive that money
because they're deciding to then take
those savings and spend it elsewhere in
the economy so this is one of those
things that say it does have a lasting
effect on more than just the person who
is receiving
the loan forgiveness
and i think a lot of people are like oh
a little very selfish one-sided because
like oh well you're getting forgiven
alone why wasn't i forgiven alone right
well look you had republicans in here
have been talking about
all these other things to to help your
to to help you as as a
as a us citizen right as someone and
it's just not
it is not something they want to do
democrats are the only ones who are
willing to go through and we've seen
that in the last
month
under biden right
uh pac-tac chips act the inflation act
uh
right now reducing
the or the helping student loans with
her with their student loan forgiveness
this is something that only only
democrats
have offered to do republicans have
stood by in an anti-american policy and
said we won't help you we won't we won't
help you in any way that makes your life
easier as an american living in this
country
so
this is you know as someone who was a
recipient of pell grants and who did
have to refinance and who did have to
pay off loans
i am so happy for those people who are
now going to be getting the the aid that
they have right now
well
and and i i am someone who paid off my
loans um again i didn't carry my loans
very long because
because i actually i i'm a college
dropout and that and that i think is um
some of the people who are mad because
they did pay off their loans um
and people who have worked hard to pay
off their loans i worked hard to pay off
what was remaining on my loans right
years ago but i'm not mad because the
american people and the american working
class are receiving a cost reduction
which is going to i don't know
help the american working class and i
think that's important uh we have brett
minzellos with us brett what do you make
of what do you make of this development
where the president's going to come out
and speak to us today
oh i mean let's be real here this is the
largest student loan relief that we've
ever seen in american history and so i
think we need to be cognizant of that
fact and this is going to help so many
americans and i believe like 90 plus
percent of the relief is going to be to
people earning less than 75 000 a year
so this is going to disproportionately
help the people who need it most which i
think is great i think it's funny to see
the antibody response from republicans
anytime a policy is presented that is
something that actually helps people
instead of major businesses uh
billionaires things like that it's like
you could give all the relief all the
tax cuts all the bailouts to businesses
and billionaires in the world and
republicans cheer it on but the second
you decide to give a single bit of
relief to the average american all of a
sudden it's oh this is going to cause
inflation this is going to cause all
these problems it's like they are just
so afraid to help regular americans and
i think they realize that once people
start to feel the effects of this
they're going to be like oh this is
great actually this is really good and
really helpful and all these attacks on
biden about socialism or whatever are
just ridiculous i mean let's face it the
system is extremely broken i'm curious
to hear the details of this plan when
president biden lays them out because
what i don't want is i don't want to see
a temporary benefit you know that all of
a sudden next year we still have the
same problems and it just keeps going on
and on and on so what i want to learn
and dig deeper on um is how is this
going to not just be a band-aid on the
wound but how is this actually going to
heal the wound going forward and allow
this not to happen again and again and
put people in this cycle because
what it does is when people are saddled
with this
student loan debt they're not able to
take the risks that are necessary for
them to really go out there and succeed
they're not able to
be entrepreneurial in many aspects
they're not able to take chances on
careers and they just don't have that
that safety net and it's really because
there's a system that is
uh very predatory on on people who are
making decisions at times when let's
face it i mean do you know everything
about life when you're like 18 years old
and are trying to make your your future
decisions so it's it's extremely
predatory and i think at minimum we got
to get rid of all this interest that's
been stacking up and and to me i think
you know and i want to hear the details
of the plan to see exactly what it does
but you know if if you owe twenty
thousand dollars on your loans and you
paid twenty thousand dollars to interest
i think that should just go and apply
straight to your principal um i i don't
think people should be making exorbitant
amounts of money off struggling students
who
who need help and are just trying to
to better their lives here because
that's the other thing too is like you
know as as someone who took out student
loans right both pell and and private
loans like it is one of those things
that really come to get you which is
like where do you sit is it you know
variable interest fixed interest like
how high are those interest rates you
know especially as you come out of
college like oh shoot like i should you
know knowing or maybe not knowing too is
like which one should i be paying off
first right you're like oh i gotta make
sure that i pay off the highest interest
one first but yeah like how do i how do
i cut costs and and save money so that i
can apply more do i have to refinance
like
in and of itself like inherently the
higher education system is flawed it is
broken in the way in which we price it
in a way in which you get benefit of
your education yeah um
and as you said the predatory factor of
like private banking institutions
giving you money and it like you know
i as an 18 year old can take out this
amount of money
at a high interest rate to pay for
college but i don't have certain rights
elsewhere like it doesn't make a lot of
sense and so right now this 10 to 20
dollars is an amazingly uh
big accomplishment for the buying
administration and everyone who will
receive those savings but also it is
something where it's like well we should
it is something that we need to look at
as the overall higher education
continuing education sector to say like
how can we benefit so next generation
and the next classes that come through
these schools
aren't
uh aren't uh victims of the same problem
right we're like fixing something right
now but then continuing on past this how
are we going to help those who want to
get an education and who want and need
to get those loans uh down the line
i just want to bring up a an article
from october of 2020 that you won't see
any republicans referencing today and
it's about how lenders forgave 287
million dollars in unpaid debt by donald
trump and you never heard anyone blink
an eye when donald trump's debt was
forgiven they a quote unquote
billionaire's debt was forgiven to the
tune of 287 million dollars and you can
look that up in market watch it's
reported all over the place and you
forget how people and
especially people close to trump took
advantage of that ppp loan program at
the beginning of the pandemic and really
just took all of our money uh didn't
have to pay back those loans and
basically scammed the american public
out of millions and millions and
millions of dollars and nobody batted an
eye at that so i think all all relief is
good but i want to make sure that we're
you know helping those underlying issues
like you said gabe so that going forward
that this isn't a a recurring issue that
we have and i think also like hey you
got to look at things like times change
things change because somebody's doing
something good now um
you know you can't be that selfish to
not want people to succeed now because
you may have not have had that
opportunity i mean think about like
advancements in
in medicine and things like that like
yes i'm sure there are a lot of people
who you know when certain
treatments came out for certain kinds of
cancers and and whatnot there were
people who felt like you know if only i
had this you know 10 years ago but does
that mean everyone right now deserves to
die no i think it's it's great and we
should be helping all these people with
everything we can and the fact that
president biden is taking an action like
you said gabe that he really doesn't
have to do but that he wants to uphold
this promise that he made during the
campaign and he's doing what we can i
think we need to look at that and and
say hey we're moving the ball forward
here and that's a good thing well i
think the context of this is great like
you said because we can even go back to
other campaigns or presidential
campaigns that's having said that
joe biden is going to try to uh deliver
on his promise that he gave the american
people in 2020 because we have to we
have to give it that context right
because you remember when mitt romney
was like ah if you want to go to college
just borrow a million dollars from your
parents right like if you want to start
a business just borrow a million bucks
you know yeah because every parent has a
million dollars their parents right i
mean we have we have this uh situation
um where during the pandemic i think the
american people learned a lot about
ourselves but more than anything they
learned about our system of government
and they learned about our society and
our culture because there was a lot of
people who who struggle to even afford
college
who were called essential workers and
said nope you have to work
you have to work during a pandemic and
there were other folks who weren't
allowed to work during the pandemic and
they discovered that the government
could save their the business
that they worked for they would save
them i mean they gave him you know some
crumbs right you know 800 bucks or
whatever it was to get through the next
eight or nine months
but then when the democrats came in
march of 2021 and actually delivered a
package of covet relief that was for the
american people i think people
discovered hey our labor is something
that we actually barter with and
and we actually can't afford to give the
american working class
uh actual benefits inside of our
government because it's ours it's our
country it's our government we don't
have to cater to the billionaires who
want to wipe away hundreds of millions
of dollars worth of debt we can actually
do that for i don't know the american
working class and i think that is the
most important component of this is that
in this moment when joe biden could say
look we have record low unemployment
wages are on their way up the stock
market's up the economy there's high
demand in the economy
i don't think it's a good time to really
be
lowering the cost on americans at this
point and spending feder spending quote
unquote federal dollars
on this forgiveness of these loans he
absolutely could say that he could
renege on his on his
campaign promise turn tail and run
easily but he's not because i truly
believe with the infrastructure bill
with the pact act with the chips bill um
with uh what what he wanted with bill
back better which became the
inflation reduction act with the coveted
relief and now with this movement on the
student let
student loan debt plan
joe biden his number one concern is the
american people it is the american
working class and his aim is to deliver
for
couldn't be them
more with what he's got tony right
really i mean he is betting he is
betting on america right right you've
got the chips act which is trying to
make our country an actual person or
actual entity that will compete against
someone who is uh overseas right we want
to bring those jobs to america the thing
that republicans have said they would do
over and over again was we'll give you a
credit we'll give you a tax credit if
you keep jobs here and they go well
actually i can make i can save more
money if i send them overseas right it's
made in america or you know as much as
trump wants to say it's always made in
china for him or some other country that
isn't america uh well all of his
products are to be fair so that's right
exactly looking at it through that
length i mean let's just be real about
how out of touch these people are i mean
you still have mitch mcconnell to this
day making statements saying that
americans are still
living off the paychecks they received
in the coveted relief act he believes
that people are still living off the
twelve hundred dollar checks the six
thousand dollars
i mean that isn't if you really think
that an average american is surviving on
600 for over a year or over really the
course of a week or two like like that
is so out of touch and that's what they
think of the american people they just
want to throw them crumbs while they're
getting billions and billions of dollars
in their corrupt relationships and
everything that they're doing and nobody
calls them out on it so we got to call
them out on it but i mean i want to
point you to this brian tyler cohen post
which over which has a nice overview of
a lot of those accomplishments we were
talking about 10k and student loan debt
limited up to 20k actually the inflation
reduction act which is also remember the
biggest climate bill in all of history
the american rescue plan infrastructure
the biggest gun reform package that we
have seen in decades chips the packed
act the most jobs added lowest
unemployment in 50 years we got rid of
the al-qaeda leader and now let's look
at the republican platform who just says
no to everything no to everything for
the american people but then they throw
on a little sprinkles of fascism there
so what they want to do as well is
defund the fbi dissolve the justice
department they want to prevent sick
veterans from getting health care they
want to eliminate your social security
and medicare they want to force 10 year
olds to carry their rapist baby to term
they want to lock up dr fauci they want
to ban and burn books i mean the two
parties aren't even remotely similar
here and so i think that's important as
we head into the midterms with this
renewed energy to understand the stakes
and understand what republicans are
trying to do they're trying to take away
your freedoms they're trying to take
away everything that we have fought for
in this country and they try to house it
in this term woke which really just
means to actually be aware to injustices
and to want the world to be a better
more equal place ask them to define it
they can't honestly without sounding
incredibly racist because because that's
the
every everything that they have brought
forward is anti-american right they do
not want to cross the aisle and help any
american when it comes to democratic
policies and bettering their their lives
and those that you know they care for
right they are unwilling
to to bring jobs to america they are
unwilling to
help out people who have loans they're
unwilling to
uh to help with health care i mean these
are the infrastructure in which our
country is built on
they are unwilling to do anything that
is pro-american these patriots the
people that say they are pro-america and
they're patriotic and they will live and
die and these colors don't bleed
[ __ ] these republicans will take any
money they can from lobbyists and they
will screw over the constituents that
they were elected to represent and they
will not do anything they will abandon
them and take whatever money they can
financial incentive and say for those
people that elected them yeah good luck
no i'm not going to really care about
you and that's what it is at the core i
mean even you brought up the loans that
were forgiven for trump you look at the
loans the the bailouts that were done
for banks uh the airline industry and
even despite them saying do not do stock
buybacks they said okay we won't and
then did stock buybacks and they said we
need more money and when asked where did
the money go that we told you not to use
for stock buybacks they said well we did
it for stock buybacks no penalties ceos
and corporate execs get uh golden
parachutes and handcuffs they're
no problem no problem whatsoever with
those people from the republican party
and somebody astutely pointed out in the
comments also don't forget the trillions
of dollars in tax cuts that donald trump
gave to the rich right once again no
issues there and by the way like biden
is crushing it on the debt and the
deficit like biden is lowering the debt
lowering the deficit democrats always do
they always do this is this this is a
continuing narrative in this country
republicans always put us economically
in a rough situation they always do and
because they're not looking out for the
actual people in this country biden
trust of the american people i think
that's really what this tell is today
because as we're waiting here i want to
give everyone context we're waiting uh
for president biden to make his remarks
here at the white house now on this
student debt uh relief program that he's
going to be talking about today for
anyone listening and
joining us now we're going to be soon
going to the white house here
for these remarks from the from
president biden but i really think that
people
they forget about that all the time is
that republicans destroy everything look
at any chart look at any graph any chart
just look at the raw numbers it all
shows there and by the way we did an ad
about this but donald trump before he
became president even said that the
democrats are better uh for the economy
before he decided to become a republican
and run and pull one over the economy
and destroy
the republican party
stands on this christian
platform
right and remember christians uh you
know what what what did the christians
say about forgiveness i heard something
about forgiveness right right you know
it's like you know i will house i will
care for the sick i will help you out in
any ways that i can because i will care
for you as a fellow human being not just
a christian are they really christians
but they're not so you know if we talk
about forgiveness they are willing to
forgive their own sins
to which they play victim for
and unwilling to help or forgive those
who actually need it i mean here's the
problem could anybody genuinely say this
is fair can anybody say it's fair where
say you have to take out 50 000 in loans
for college and many people are taking
out much more than that but then when
you pay it back you pay back your 50k
and you've barely even paid towards your
principal oh yeah because all your money
has gone to interest is that fair is
that fair
is it fair to take out a 50 000 loan and
ultimately you're end up paying over the
course of your life 150k 200k for that
50k i mean that's just [ __ ] and i
think most americans understand that
that's [ __ ] understand that that's
an unfair system that's stacked against
them that's just making other people
wealthy at their expense at them and
it's preventing them from being able to
live their dreams and and pursue all
their ambitions and and whatnot and uh
you know it's it's garbage but i think
you know as we see the polls kind of
shift we saw a reuters poll today show
that president biden's ratings were
higher than they've been since before
the summer well and also the news
yeah and i think you're seeing this i
think you're basically seeing now that
i'll call it the coalition of the normal
i think it's the coalition of people who
by the way
may not be on the right or may not be on
the left when it comes to a lot of these
issues but they see just common sense
policies and the democrats are the ones
right now pursuing just common sense
policies like if republicans could try
going to like a gun violence issue for
example republicans could try to act
like ooh spooky scary democrats are
trying to take your guns the center of
the country the the middle of the
country most americans
something like 75 80 percent of
americans actually want common sense
restrictions on guns they want gun
safety reform i mean that's not a
radical issue so i think you're getting
all these people who are kind of more
center-minded but in our country
center-minded happens to be what
republicans think of as the far left but
people who want to have well it's
radical brett radical very radical
radical to have health care it's radical
to be able to afford to pay for college
it's radical to be able to get insulin
at an affordable price it's radical to
be able to get cancer treatment if
you're a veteran who served our country
and i think we have americans
across the country right now being like
that [ __ ] doesn't sound very radical to
me actually that sounds like stuff i'm
i'm i'm pretty into so as a result
you're seeing people come out in waves
like in the new york 19 election where
you have a republican trying to hammer
home you know inflation inflation
inflation you know these economic issues
that people realize are global issues
that have been getting better each and
every month as the economy is doing
blockbuster jobs numbers and whatnot and
then you have the democrat who very
early on made the core of their campaign
this notion of republicans want to take
away your rights and abortion is a key
issue and most americans want to not be
restricted have these crazy complete
abortion bans whereby the government is
mandating what you can do with your body
and so those things are resonating
people are waking up we saw it in kansas
we saw it in new york 19 and i think
we're going to see a huge blue wave in
november i and it's going to take all of
us but the reason i'm saying it is not
to say oh we could sit home and relax no
no i want you to be energized we got a
lot i want you to be excited we got to
lean into it we got to be ready and we
got to be pumped up and we got to get
everybody as excited as we are about
these results and everybody is
passionate to push back against this
authoritarianism that is coming our way
because without it you know it's it's on
us at the end of the day to spread these
messages we've already seen what kind of
the corporate media does and how they
handle joe biden's accomplishments but
we're pushing we're defying the odds
against that that race last night in new
york 19 there were some polls that had
the republican up by as much as 10
points right they had that as a lean r
district now think about that every time
you go on 538 or real clear politics or
whatever website you use to look at the
aggregation of polls all those districts
that are lean are by a few points by
plus five plus six guess what [ __ ]
it doesn't matter it's not taking into
account rovember which is what we call
it here rovember row row row your vote
we are coming for this we are going to
protect our freedoms and the freedoms of
all freedom-loving americans well i i
think that's a great point because
follow the minus touch network while
you're here subscribe if you're if
you're listening you're not going to
want to miss a thing because i think
democrats have a better messaging
platform and i don't want to pat
ourselves in the back here at the minus
touch network and i mean you you brett
and ben and jordy have done such a great
job at delivering some of the messaging
for the country to really understand hey
it it is about messaging it is about
politics you do have to do this thing
and go out to win elections you have to
fight back a little bit inside this
world where
if you want to set policy you're going
to have to win places like the new york
19th that is a place where you can win
and you should win and that is i think
the most important thing is to get the
messaging out because community is
important and i think that's why beto is
doing so well in texas it's because he's
not talking he's not talking about
people's genitalia in bathrooms he's
talking about texans he's talking about
what's important to them like you said
not to go broke because of a damn
medical bill yeah i mean your kid's
worried that they're gonna get killed by
a weapon of war at a school i mean he's
talking about the real issues that the
community wants the politicians to talk
about it is it is vitally important that
our people who set policy for us in our
government because it's ours whether
it's a state or the federal government
it's ours they are they are doing the
things that the community wants and the
community needs and i think that's what
this is today from the president and the
remarks that we're going to hear the the
other thing i want to bring up is like
what is being announced today is a great
start right like
in the same way when they passed the
health care bill under the obama
administration
that was a good start right everyone was
like oh it's got to be all or nothing
right it's got to be and and mind you
like even a health care bill was very
scaled down to what it ended up being
and from there republicans tried to
strip it away to what to down to be
nothing but the way that i look at this
student loan uh forgiveness
is the same way that i looked at the
health care bill it's meant to be a
starting block to build on right it's
not meant to be like if if we could yeah
we would do it all and be great and
everyone would be happy but i mean this
is a starting block to really take a
look at the systems in place to identify
it's broken and it needed fixing now
what systemically do we need to fix here
and let's go through and actually make
uh amendments to this we make it better
but
if we live in this world that is it's
all or nothing it's bang or bust then we
won't move anywhere we won't progress to
something that is better from nothing
and so i think that a lot of people
really need to look at this right now
and and and take off the i pay for my
loans or this or that it's like look
let me tell you
we're lifting everyone up with this
let me say two things first i want to
address uh
a comment here from someone named
michael let me see if i could pull it
back up uh because this person is just a
really sad pathetic person and i think
everybody should should talk to michael
here michael said something like
you sissies are done i i'll i lost it
here but if something like
read it you sissies are never gonna take
our guns and the fbi is done see this is
just somebody in like a bizarre a weird
mag occult world like you're just not
living in reality and i feel bad for you
and i thank you for watching the maya's
touch podcast cause maybe deep down you
do want to get some truth and some facts
but let's be real nobody is coming for
your guns at all all people people just
don't want kids to be shot up in schools
and if that's too much for you then
maybe you have to reevaluate your life
choices the fbi the fbi does a lot of
has done a lot of bad things throughout
history i i'll give you that 100 percent
here they're going exactly by the book
and they are not injecting politics into
this whatsoever in fact donald trump is
the one injecting politics in this to
try to say well look at how popular i am
you can't prosecute somebody as popular
as me that's injecting politics into
this and what our fbi agents are doing
is first off they gave donald trump so
much slack here they gave him so many
opportunities dozens of opportunities to
hand over these documents he lied every
step of the way his attorneys lied every
step of the way and that's on him he
could have turned these back and this
couldn't have been an issue but there's
a reason why he's stealing those
documents and once again if this was joe
biden doing it if it was barack obama
doing if this is any president doing it
i hope the fbi would do the same exact
thing and i know that they would because
these are our top secret the highest
levels of classification of these
documents and i like how you said our i
like how you said our brain you said our
top secret documents because i think
that's where the disconnect is here for
these trumpers and trump himself is he
really doesn't fundamentally understand
that the office of the presidency is
ours it's our office we get to choose
who's there for the four years and
sometimes it's two four-year terms in a
row but we get to decide about who is in
our office now we can have those are our
documents tonight there are documents
that he's taken and when he invokes
executive privilege ironically what he's
also doing there is he is saying that
the documents that he had were property
of the us government that he took so
he's actually admitting to his crimes
right when he says that and he does not
have executive privilege the executive
is president biden the executive is the
current power office in our office and
those documents are our documents so he
is stealing from you michael if you're a
real human being but another note i
wanted to read is a quote that i saw
that resonated with me the other day
somebody on twitter um where they said
voting isn't a marriage it's public
transport you're not waiting for the one
who's absolutely perfect you're getting
the bus and if there's not one to your
destination you don't just hop on the
one heading in the opposite direction
yeah and so you know going to it back to
what gabe was saying like we constantly
want to be heading in the correct
direction and democrats are constantly
trying to take us in that correct
direction and our country is so divided
and polarized in many ways but most of
our country wants to be heading in this
better direction of affordable
drug prices of people being able to get
the health care they need people being
able to pay off student loans that's the
direction where americans want to be
heading in and so when we hear a lot
about also like these polls that say you
know 80 percent of people say america's
heading in the wrong direction uh
including 75 democrats
i want to know the next answer okay
who's taking us in the wrong direction
that they are scared of and inevitably i
think what you're finding is people like
if you ask me that question i'd probably
say the same thing because i see the
direction that these republicans are
taking us in the stripping of our rights
the uh ending of roe v wade things like
that and i say yes we are obviously
heading in the wrong direction because
of republicans right and so we need to
overcome that and that's what's on the
line here and we need to be the people
who are pushing us in the right
direction and you can't always be going
well i need to have the perfect person
to do this or if the policy is not 100
there right i'm not voting for them or
whatever because then guess what you are
handing a vote to the donald trumps to
the desantis's to the marjory taylor
greens you are giving them the power and
what they will do with it is they will
take us hard in the opposite direction
and then it's going to be that much
harder to get back the way that we want
to go and that's what we saw with trump
and now we're recovering from those
years which took us so far in the wrong
direction that piece by piece we are
piecing back together this country and
president biden has done it in the face
of unprecedented opposition here right
well you know the other thing that i
think he's done and again i don't toot
uh biden's horn a lot and i probably
should do it more but really honestly
he's done it in a way that has kind of
ignored
like the the social network and the the
yelling and screaming and the noise
right like he could have gave in to this
gas price thing he could have gave in to
all these other this all this other
noise that was being created by the the
right machine monst the right far right
monster that is that media machine he
could have gave into that the media
really gave him a tough time oh how is
donald trump being served the search
warrant for top secret doctrine does he
how was that bite for bad for biting
like what the hell are you talking about
like he could play into all that he
could be tweeting about this he could be
sitting down on the toilet really rage
tweeting but he hasn't he gets up every
morning he puts on his shoes and he goes
down to our office which he knows that
he's working for us in that office and
he's doing the things that he thinks is
best for the american people now i think
that there are several things that he
will fall short on i absolutely believe
that joe biden will not do everything
that he absolutely wants to do for the
american people but i think he gets up
every morning knowing that this is
democracy he gets up every morning
understanding what is at stake not just
for our security but also for us
economically and socially like we are
headed in a direction that we don't want
to go and i am trying to give the
american people the actual
opportunity to take their country and
take their democracy to a whole another
place to to a place where equity
equality and liberty is achieved through
democracy because i believe he believes
in those core principles and that is the
difference between the vote that
happened in 2020 is that
people chose decency the bar was that
low but we actually had someone who had
the decency to care about the american
people and i think his his statement
today will show that because he's done
it time and time again he's he's gotten
so much flack and he does something and
he shows his decency he shows his
empathy and he shows that he does care
about our democracy and he's really very
talented at knowing kind of how
washington works i mean well he's done
it for a long time he's done it he's
done it for a long time and you could
knock him for that and say he's a
product of washington which is off
nothing but he knows how to get [ __ ]
done in washington like he does and i
think that's showing with all the
legislation that he has been able to
pass i mean nobody thought that he would
get the inflation reduction act passed
nobody thought joe manchester
going to have the president i think here
in a second because uh it looks like
they just put the speech on the podium
so i want to i want to give every i want
to give everyone a um an idea again
we're on the midas touch network here
please please follow and subscribe to
the minus touch network here if you're
if you're joining us if you're just
joining us we are going to be covering
the student loan forgiveness plan and
joe biden's remarks on that plan um it
looks like they just uh came out with
the speech in a folder and put it on the
podium i'm keeping an eye here um so
we're really watching these remarks here
as we deliver them to you i didn't mean
to cut you off right i just wanted no no
that's that's a great update i'm really
excited for president biden to speak i
think this is a this is a big moment and
it's another win and a streak of biden
wins i mean you know dark brandon is
absolutely crushing it he is slaying the
naysayers and i want to bring also
attention to this new tweet from cap
action which is a brilliant response to
these uh republican uh comments about
you know basically pay back all your
loans no matter what the interest is
this is a bailout this is a handout uh
it's a brilliant tweet i'm not sure if
you're able to pull it up and cap action
but it's republican members give me if
you give me if you put the link in the
private chat there i can i can pull it
i'll do that for you so republican
members of congress whose ppp loans were
forgiven
matt gates had 476 000 of ppp loans
forgiven marjorie taylor greene had 180
000 dollars of ppp loans forgiven greg
pence mike pence's brother 79
441 forgiven vern buchanan from florida
2.8 million dollars in ppp loans
forgiven kevin hearn over 1 million
forgiven roger williams 1.43 million
bret guthrie 4.3 million ralph norman
306k ralph abraham 38k mike kelly 974k
vicky hartzler 451k mark wayne mullen
988 thousand dollars carol miller 3.1
million dollars in ppp loans forgiven so
you know what i do not want to hear one
damn thing from these republicans about
people getting ten thousand dollars in
student loans forgiven because if
they're allowed to take three plus
million dollars for themselves i think
it's okay when the average american
finally gets the relief that they need
it's just so hypocritical and it shows
you really where their interests are
their interests lie with padding their
bank accounts and helping their
billionaire friends which is why it's so
rich whenever these people uh pun
intended uh speak out against this sort
of thing when you have people who are
constantly looking for ways to defraud
the system if if he hasn't made a
comment yet i'm sure like a guy like
rick scott will make us
here comes the president i think he's
going to be coming in here uh any minute
here let me see if i can
uh but the other the other person that
uh when you bring up the list of people
like elaine chao mitch mcconnell's wife
a recipient of ppp loans like uh you
know mitch mcconnell who is in kentucky
and relies on government aid and
assistance for for constituents
you know the guy who is willing to
criticize others for getting a handout
is silent when it comes to the loans
here's here's the first years universal
education is not enough
and that we're going to be out competed
by the rest of the world if we don't
take action
but here's the deal
the cost of education beyond high school
has gone up significantly
the total cost to attend a public
four-year
university has tripled nearly tripled in
40 years
tripled
instead of properly funding public
colleges many states have cut back their
support we're just talking about that in
the oval many states have cut back
support for
their state universities
leaving students to pick up more of the
tab
in 50 years for 50 years pell grants
have been a key way for the federal
government to help lower income families
particularly those earning less than
sixty thousand dollars a year to send
their kids to college
those pell grants used to cover
eighty percent
eighty percent of the cost of going to a
public four-year college
today
pell grants
cover 30 30
roughly 32 percent
that's one-third of the cost as opposed
to before
it matters i remember walking up now
my dad like probably a lot of your folks
cared a lot about your education
my dad's greatest regret was that he
never got to go to college
and my dad was a very well-read man
particularly history and uh
um but it was a great regret you always
say joey you're gonna be a college man
and i'd say dad but
what does that matter i mean you can
still get fired if you're a college man
he said yeah but they can never take it
away from you they can never take your
education away
and i remember my senior year i got into
uh
one of the little ivies and i got into a
number of schools and we're trying to
get the money even with financial
assistance to be able to go there
we had four kids all of uh all of us
wanting to go to school
and um
i remember going down after a baseball
game i
went to a really good school up in
clemont delaware on the pennsylvania
border
and uh drove down to newark delaware
where my dad worked at an automobile
agency
and i walked in and i had my spikes and
because the reason i was going down when
your dad works an automobile agency the
great advantage you get a new car to go
to the prom or
you could use car if the light you think
i'm joking i'm not joking and so i went
down to my 51 plymouth
with
beach towels for seat covers
and uh i had my uniform on my spikes off
i ran in and the woman's name was mary
who ran the place i said mary where's
dad said he's out in the lane going into
the in the repair shop
give my word true story
and my dad was a well-dressed refined
fella and i walked out and my dad was
pacing back and forth between the big
garage door going into the
into the uh repair shop
and the door going out of the showroom
and they looked up he said oh joey
honey i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry i thought god something
happened this before cell phones saw
something happen to one of my brothers
or my sister or my mom or something i
said what's the matter dad he said i
want to see the guy's name was charlie
delter who was a
vice president of the farmer's bank
which was a state-owned bank that did a
lot of the financing of people wanting
to purchase a car
said i went to charlie and asked to
borrow the money
he said
he won't lend it to me he said i'm so
ashamed
i'm so damn ashamed
you know my dad would you know
my dad was like millions of parents all
across the country
i want to help the kids to get to school
but there was just no way to be able to
do it
you know
and because he believed as i do that
education is a ticket to a better life
but something jill and i kamal and doug
we understand deeply i'm sure the vast
majority of you do as well
but over time that ticket has become too
expensive for too many americans
all all this means is the entire an
entire generation is now saddled with
unsustainable debt in exchange for an
attempt at least at a college degree
the burden is so heavy that even if you
graduate you may not have access to the
middle class life that the college
degree once provided
many people many people can't qualify
for a mortgage to buy a home because of
the debt they continue to carry
they uh you know they they carry is too
high they can't come up with the down
payment anyway
a lot of folks are even putting off uh
starting families because of the cost
and the dream of starting or owning your
own business is just way off in the
distance with the debt that's that so
many years saddled with
many of you had to leave school because
of financial strain was much too high
about a third of the borrowers have debt
but no degree
and worst of both worlds debt and no
degree
the burden is especially heavy on black
and hispanic borrowers who on average
have less family wealth to pay for it
there's no they don't own their homes to
borrow against to be able to pay for
college
and the pandemic only made things worse
but we responded aggressively to the
pandemic to minimize the economic impact
of the harm of covenant imposed on
individuals families and businesses you
all were there with recovery look we
increased unemployment benefits for
workers who were laid off
we provided loans to small businesses so
they could stay afloat and take care of
their families and their employees we
provided assistance to people to put
food on the table remember those long
lines you guys would all film of cars
decent looking car not jalopies you know
nice cars
just waiting for a box of food to be put
in the trunk
in the united states of america
waiting for over an hour to get food in
a trunk
and we provided rent and mortgage
assistance to keep people from being
evicted and thrown out in the street
our approach to help americans who need
it the most was necessary
and it was the right thing to do and it
helped people avoid financial crisis
which helped our whole country as a
consequence of that that didn't benefit
them it benefited the whole economy
our approach is why america's economic
recovery
economic recovery was faster
and stronger than any other advanced
nation in the world
and now it's time to address the burden
of student debt in the same way
working closely with the secretary of
education he's got the hard job
you know
secretary cardona
here's what my administration is going
to do to provide more breathing room for
people so they have less burden by
student debt
and quite frankly to fix the system
itself which we came in we both
acknowledge was broken
in terms of anyway
there are three key factors what we're
going to do today
first we've made incredible progress
advancing america's economic recovery
we've wound down pandemic relief
programs like the ones our unemployment
insurance and small businesses
it's time we do the same thing for
student
loans
student loan payments pause is going to
end
it's going to end december 30. i'm
extending to december 31st
2022 and it's going to end at that time
it's time for the payments to resume
second
my campaign for president i made a
commitment i made a comment that would
provide student debt relief
and i'm honoring that commitment today
using the authority congress grant at
the department of education
we will forgive
ten thousand dollars in outstanding
federal student loans
in addition students who come from
low-income families
which allow them to qualify to receive a
pell grant
will have their debt reduced 20
000
both of these targeted actions are for
families who need it the most
working and middle class people hit
especially hard during the pandemic
making under
125 000 a year
you make more than that you don't
qualify
no high income individual or high income
household
on top of the five percent in the top
five percent of incomes by the way
will benefit from this action period
in fact about ninety percent of the end
of the the eligible beneficiaries make
under seventy five thousand dollars a
family
here's what that means
if you make under 125 000 you get ten
thousand dollars knocked off your
student debt
if you make under 125 000 a year and you
received a pell grant
you'll get an additional ten thousand
dollars knocked off that total for a
total of twenty thousand dollar relief
95 of the borrowers can benefit from
these actions
that's
43 million people
of the 43 million
over 60 percent are pell grant
recipients that's 27 million people who
will get 20 000 in debt relief
nearly 45 percent can have their student
debt fully cancelled
that's 20 million people who can start
getting on with their lives all this
means people can start finally crawl out
from under that mountain of debt
to get on top of their rent and their
utilities
to finally think about buying a home or
starting a family or starting a business
and by the way
when this happens the whole economy is
better off
in the coming weeks the department of
education will lay out in detail
a short and simple form to apply for
this relief along with information when
this application process opens
by resuming student loan payments at the
same time
as we provide targeted relief we're
taking an economically responsible
course
as a consequence
about 50 billion dollars a year will
start coming back into the
treasury because the resumption of debt
independent experts agree that these
actions taken together
will provide real benefits for families
without meaningful effect on inflation
let's be clear
i hear it all the time
how do we pay for it
we pay for it by what we've done
last year we cut the deficit by more
than 350
billion dollars
this year we're on track to cut that by
more than 1.7 trillion by the end of
this fiscal year
the single largest deficit reduction in
a single year in the history of america
and the inflation reduction accident cut
it by another 300 billion over the next
decade because medicare will be paying
less for prescription drugs
and over a trillion dollars we add it
out for the next two decades
the point is this
there is plenty of deficit reduction to
pay for the program's cumulative deficit
and play for the programs many times
over
i will never apologize for helping
americans working working america's
middle class
especially not to the same folks who
voted for a two trillion dollar tax cut
that mainly benefited the wealthiest
americans and the biggest corporations
that slowed the economy didn't do a lot
for an economic growth and wasn't paid
for
and racked up this enormous deficit
just as we've never apologized when the
federal government forgave almost every
single cent
of over 700 billion dollars in loans to
hundreds of thousands of small
businesses across the across america
during the pandemic
no one complained that those loans
caused inflation
a lot of these folks in small businesses
are working in middle class families
they needed help it was the right thing
to do
so the outrage over helping working
people
with student with student loans i think
is just simply wrong dead wrong
third thing
we're fixing the student loan program
system itself
we've talked about this at len this is
really important
we're proposing to make what's called an
income driven repayment plan simple and
fair and here's how
no one with an undergraduate loan today
or in the future whether for community
college or four-year college will have
to pay more than five percent
of their discretionary income to repay
their loan
that's income after you pay the
necessities like housing food and the
like
you currently pay 10
we're cutting that in half to 5
and after you pay your loan for 20 years
your obligation will be fulfilled if it
hadn't already been fulfilled meaning
you won't have to pay any more period
and borrows your original balance was
less than 12 000
many of whom are community college
students
will be done paying just after 10 years
these changes will save more than a
thousand dollars a year on average for
the borrower
it's a game changer
we're also fixing what's called and this
has been the bane of
driving me crazy when i was out of
office
the public service loan forgiveness
program
now this program forgives student loans
to encourage those students who had
those loans if they go and do public
service
think of the millions who are
public school teachers
local police officers
workers at local charities
members of the military and the national
guard
and so many more think of the folks who
work for federal state local tribal
governments keeping essential services
going responding to natural disasters
all those firefighters and cops
the program is designed so that if you
serve in one of these jobs
and we'll be able to list those and
you'll be able to accurately assess
whether you do
and make your loan payments for 10 years
even if it's not consecutive years
your remaining balance will be
completely forgiven
it's a great idea but the program's a
mess
it's so inefficient and complicated too
many people just give up
think if a service member defers their
student loan payment while they're
deployed the system is so restrictive
that their active duty service didn't
count as public service
and the loan isn't forgiven as promised
it's outrageous
well the man to my left is going to fix
it the department of education has
recently proposed changes that will make
this program work better
and over the long term
much better
and now the department
issues emergency temporary changes to
retroactively credit public service
so accounts
and loans are forgiven
since i've been in office more than 175
000 teachers
nurses
police officers have been able to get
over 10 billion dollars in loan
forgiveness so far through this program
but this opportunity expires on october
31st 2022
so my message to all servants
all public servants all those who are
the ones that are volunteering
is
out with student debt
to go here's what you want if you if
you're worried about how to do it go to
pslf.gov
before october 31st to see if you
qualify for public service to student
loan forgiveness
this is another game changer and we're
going to have people who are there to
help get you help help direct you and
work your work through the process
and one more big change we're making to
the system is we're holding colleges
accountable for jacking up costs without
delivering value to students
we've all heard of those schools luring
students with a promise of big paychecks
when they graduate only to watch these
students be ripped off and left with
mountains of debt
and my processors looked the other way
for some reason with good reason
to do anything about this fraud my
administration is taking it on for
example
the department of education works with
private education associations to
accredited college to accredit colleges
and universities so they can receive
federal aid
well last week the department of
education
fired a college accreditor that allowed
colleges like itt and corinthian to
defraud borrowers
and combined with our emergency actions
the public service forgiveness program
and other acts we've taken we've been
able to cancel more than 32 billion
dollars in student debt for 1.6 million
bars including those defrauded by these
bad acting schools
our goal is to shine a light on the
worst actors so students can avoid these
dead traps
now
i understand not every one thing every
not everything i'm announcing today is
going to make everybody happy
something is too much
i find it interesting how some of my
republican friends who voted for those
tax cuts and others think
that we shouldn't be helping these folks
something is too little
but i believe my plan is responsible and
fair
it focuses the benefit on middle class
and working families
it helps both current and future
borrowers
and will fix a badly broken system
these actions build on my
administration's effort to make college
more affordable in the first place
it includes unprecedented investments
nearly 6 billion in historic black
colleges universities
much of which is focused on pandemic
relief to help students
cover tuition
and other costs so they could stay in
school
and i must be honest with you
i'm going to continue to fight for
doubling the pell grants i didn't get
that done this time
let me say it again
12 years of universal education is not
enough
i'm going to continue to work for
universal pre-k
for every three and four-year-old
and universal community college for
education beyond high school
let me close with
i ran for office to grow the economy
from the bottom up in the middle out
because when we do that everybody does
better everybody does well
the wealthy do very well the poor have a
way up and the middle class can have
breathing room
and that's going to help america win the
economic competition of the 21st century
because much of my time
is spent how do we remain the most
competitive nation in the world
with the strongest economy in the world
with the greatest opportunities in the
world
that's what today's announcement is
about
it's about opportunity
it's about giving people a fair shot
it's about
the one word america can be defined by
possibilities
it's all about providing possibilities
we're going to have a lot more to say
about this there's a lot of material
that's going to be put out as to how
this is being implemented and i want to
thank you all and god bless you all
thank you thank you thank you mr
president how much advance did you have
so there we have the president united
states
he's going to be uh taking some
questions here so we're going to listen
to a few oh no he's not going to take
questions he's going to
walk out here and not take any more
questions especially when it has to
pertain to do with
mar-a-lago
um gabe there's a few notes that i want
to talk about here as we
as we uh exit here from the press
conference about student known student
debt relief um he said bottom up and
middle out that's just what we were
talking about on our show earlier now
bottom up and middle out
he really does seem concerned with the
american people that seems to be at the
forefront of his mind when he's
developing this program i want i want to
uh give you a contrast here of something
he talked about the department of
education because all this comes from
the department of education
the republican party the the q and
honors the gqp
the america first fascist who are
running around um having nazi rallies
everywhere talking about destroying our
democracy because they want to end they
want to abolish is their word the
department of education right um here uh
here
president biden lays out a third of the
debt that is actually out there that
this is going to affect um
they people have no degree so they went
and they they took out debt with no
degree
uh also the pell grants aren't just for
low-income folks they are also for for
people coming out of high school they
are also low-income folks who are trying
to enter back into an economy where they
can have a degree so they they get out
of high school they do uh they have a
job for a long time they have a family
and they're trying to one-up themselves
in the economy trying to do better in
the economy by going and get getting a
degree so those people actually receive
pell grants as we mentioned on our show
the tony michael podcast before 43
million the president said
60
of those pell grants um so 43 million
people actually have student debt in
this country but 60
that that is a huge number of people who
are receiving pell grants meaning that
they don't really have the funds to
afford to go to college in this modern
day that's what that that's what that is
and and i think the important thing to
remember here is that when people say
like oh you know you should be able to
pay back your student loan that you took
out okay the
the comparison that is made from those
people like the gop right you've got jim
jordan making these statements the thing
to keep in mind is that the cost of
education
was significantly less than what it is
now
and again it has exponentially risen
over the rate of inflation year over
year over year over a year especially
for these private institutions
so that is something to remember that
like oh well you just paid off well it's
not it's not the same as if you know
years ago
you know when we were in school or our
parents were in school or their parents
were in school like the cost of
education has exponentially grown over
the rate of inflation
in this country and it has made it more
and more difficult for people to afford
and then pay off those loans especially
as interest rates rise well that's
that's an important point because the
president also said in this program that
the
the actual
maximum amount that you will pay for
your loan each year
is going to go from 10 of your
discretionary income which means after
your expenses your mortgage and all that
kind of stuff um
we'll go from 10 to 5 so it's going to
be cut in half so it's not just going to
be loan forgiveness yeah this program is
just not loan forgiveness in an amount
because 45
of the loans that are out there
will be gone right because of this
program
so they won't have to be saddled with
that burden of knowing that debt is
there
but the most important factor
is
not only will
all those people be able to now use that
money in other ways in our economy which
will grow our economy because that's how
economics work you're in a in a liberal
democracy where we we we practice
capitalism but also
if the people who are still going to be
paying payments this is important yeah
people who are still going to be paying
towards the student loans are going to
have some of their payments cut in half
so that leaves more discretionary
spending to go back into our economy to
help the american people and i want to
also mention one other thing that i
think is very impressive with this
program
is the 10-year 20-year rule
because biden also mentioned that
they want to implement this 10-year
20-year gone rule which means if you pay
on your student loans for 20 years no
matter how long you pay for it it
doesn't matter it's gone it's gone at
that point you paid 20 years of your
life towards
five percent and i think that's where
why he said it there because he kind of
mentioned this after the five percent
rule so going from ten percent to five
percent what the america what joe
biden's saying to the american people i
think
the president united states is saying i
think if you pay
five percent of your discretionary
income
every year towards your education
that should be enough to say that you've
done your you've done and paid your debt
for that education and i think that's
very important when he's talking to the
american people saying these things
yeah no i think i think it is incredibly
important you know again going back to
this um you know bottom up and middle
out right like you have to be looking
forward how to help
uh the american people right the middle
class and those who are
in the lower class area like you have to
be looking out for those people because
those are the people
that are working working in this economy
right generating
uh the the stimulation within the
economy those are the people that matter
and those are the people that we should
be looking out for in any way that we
can you know just because it's 10 to 20k
right now from you know 10 for private
and 20 for pell grants like he even said
there is more that i want to do but we
need to remember the most important
thing out of all of this
not only because going from ten to five
percent is a big [ __ ] deal okay i'll
just say that that is that is no that is
no small thing and taking that in
addition to the 10 to 20k in loan
forgiveness
these are things that will greatly help
people that are struggling because the
democrats joe biden
are actually caring for the american
people despite what republicans say oh
we'll get to it we'll do it and they
never do
they will do whatever they can to screw
over the constituents that have voted
them into office that they elected to
protect them right they elected these
people to protect them and then on the
other side you've got these republicans
that say
well you know
pull yourself up by your bootstraps and
figure it out right no sort of aid no
sort of assistance no sort of safety net
to make sure that we don't fail
as a country
and that is what joe biden and the
democrats have done even in this last
month or so of passing these different
acts they are investing and betting on
america they are investing and betting
on the american people to say look we
know times trust is incredibly tough
and we want to help you so that you can
make this country
exactly what we have dreamt it to be
and then
it's it's it's that easy to look at the
party that is helping and doing
something to help us as americans and
the party that it just sits by and says
well they want to abolish the department
of education right
yeah well we talked about it today on
our show and i i i don't want to i don't
want to give too much of shameless blood
but please go over to our channel the
tony michaels podcast and follow us we
have a show every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and we
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page so go over to our youtube channel
the tony michaels podcast and follow us
there but today on our show we talked
about the the the stark
historical contrast today where the
president united states is coming out
and delivering yet again for the
american people as he says bottom up
middle out and then we have the former
guy
the former guy down at the wall down at
the the the fake white house at
mar-a-lago hiding documents a judge says
no this order is [ __ ] you're in the
wrong court it looks like it's written
in crown he's he's yelling and screaming
apparently and his staff and his list i
want my documents back right
he says i want my documents and he
doesn't understand that those are our
documents it's our office it's our
government it's ours the people it's
ours we voted it's ours and i think the
stark contrast here to today of the
president united states joe biden coming
out and delivering again once again for
the american people even at the calls
that it he would not be able to do it
he's done it again
time and time again he's delivered he
delivered today on student loan debt for
all the people who were naysayers
and some of them on the left and we'll
talk about that in a second
but the stark contrast
that joe biden understands that that
office of the presidency is the american
people's office
and he is there to put his shoes on and
get up every morning to work for the
american people regardless of what state
they live in what county who they voted
for what their ideology is what their
religion is
he doesn't care he's there to make sure
that he gives the best opportunity and
the most trust to the american people to
do what's right for america and give
them that opportunity to prove it now i
want to go to the people who are
naysayers because we've seen a lot of
this all or nothing stuff as well today
it's not just the right wing he was like
abolish the department of education and
see where that gets you like yeah we
want to all be really dumb in this
country is what we want to do
but we see the naysayers on the other
side who are saying
all or nothing this isn't enough this
isn't enough let me remind everyone
again
let me remind everyone again who say
this is not enough
45 percent now again this is all loans
because this this is important this is
super important none of this benefit
will go to people who make 125 000 or
more what joe biden is saying is if you
can afford your student loans we're
going to make you pay them and that
starts at the end of this year we are
not pausing payments anymore from now on
you have to pay because we're doing this
program and if you make over a certain
amount of money you won't you won't
benefit from this if you have enough
money to do this
so having said that all the people who
can't afford their loans
45
of all loans outstanding are going to be
gone they're going to be wiped off the
books i think a lot of people who are
the oh all or nothing don't understand
that so many people are gonna have all
their student don't debt gone it's gone
it it is gone it is paying for people's
student debt cause so many people i mean
here a third of all the debt outstanding
people don't even have degrees it's like
me i i dropped out of college twice gabe
i had loans each time and i had to pay
back those loans now i don't begrudge
people who still have loan debt and i
don't say oh well they don't deserve it
because i didn't get it i mean i
benefited from those few those federal
student loan programs to get the college
education that i still don't have a
degree for right but that's the point
here is that everyone all the naysayers
of the all or nothing you know this is
like uh tyt young turk stuff nina turner
stuff um they say all or nothing it's
not enough but it but it if you look at
what is actually going to do yeah it
really is a lot it's a lot further it'll
make a huge impact 45 of all loans are
gone and that is the most important and
it's affecting the lowest income of
people in this country the people who
trade their labor they count on getting
these educations to go from making
minimum wage to actually having a
livable wage in this country which is
another thing we need to tackle but
right now this is a step towards that
direction because
half half
excuse me the amount that you're going
to pay of your discretionary income for
the student loan is now cut in half if
you still have a student loan lab you're
only going to have to pay for 20 years
um
now i i i am always skeptical of a
government program like this in the info
the implementation of it so we'll see
what that rollout looks like um but
hopefully hopefully it's pretty easy
when 45 percent of the debt is just gone
right i think that and i just want to
reiterate like the idea that
that it's all or nothing right it's this
or bust i think it's a very ignorant way
and naive way to look at how we are
progressing in advancing us as uh
as as the united states right we have a
problem that problem is our higher
education system
it is not only how much we have to pay
for it but what we are getting out of it
as a result and the private institutions
that can continue to increase their
price year over year of year not and
that's not even including the for-profit
institutions like uh itt or um
the other uh for-profit uh institutions
that you can take online or you know the
career colleges or what have you the
ones that have been you know uh caught a
fraud or you know um cheating students
or whatever it might be like i i forget
what the number was 20 30 billion i
forget which one he said that they have
already forgiven because of institutions
like this
um just the this past year but you you
you look at this and say like
this all or nothing
type of way of thinking is is in is is
incredibly flawed and we need to stop
and think about how this is actually
benefiting 45
or more people depending on where you
fall on the spectrum in terms of the
loans right the idea that you have to
stop and say well if i can get it
no one should get it i think that is
very ignorant yeah sure it is
unfortunate you can't get the assistance
that you want look i was the recipient
of of pell grant loans
private loans and the the government
issued pell grant loans i paid off i'm
not upset i'm not
uh uh completely um
just
uh overwhelmed in hatred toward the idea
that this was
done for other people right i am
grateful and i mean it helps us all
yes
we talked about that in our rising tide
lifts all boats right the idea that we
can help everyone right helping it yeah
it's the economy this is going to be
good for the economy which is good for
the american people um and and that is
the point going forward now ronald
mcdaniel uh brought up some kind of poll
it seemed uh a good again polls these
days are way the [ __ ] off they're
they're absolutely ridiculous most of
them are completely wrong we talked
about on our show several times um but
this poll that 59 of americans now
let me be clear not economists americans
think that this student debt relief is
going to cause inflation like what in
the hell are you talking about how in
the world is people having less
cost in their discretionary spending
going to cause inflation number one
number two i want to go back to um the
pell grant thing because i think that is
important when rona mcdaniel is trying
to make her statement because she's
trying to speak to average americans
because everyone has student loan debt
whether you're a trump supporter a
buying supporter
someone who doesn't really can even pay
attention to politics you probably have
some student loan debt or know someone
or someone in your family or affects you
in some way
back to the pell grant thing um because
i think a lot of people want to make
sure community college and stuff is um
is is free and i think we should work in
that direction but this actually works
in that direction if you think about it
because
if you have pell grants that 20-year
rule actually turns to 10 years right
which most pell grants
are done at community colleges and that
reason why is because they are lower
income people so they can't afford to
move halfway across the country they
can't afford to move to a big city uh
and afford to live in a big city to go
to a big university they have to utilize
community colleges and tech schools to
do that and i think that's important
when you talk about we're stepping from
they have to pay back all their student
loan debt to five percent of their
discretionary income cutting that in
half from 10
and then all they'll have to pay if they
receive pell grants is 10 years and
they're done so yes we're not quite
where we'd like to be with community
colleges because i really do think pell
grants and community colleges the grant
should just be your education not the
money right right and even but we're
stepping in that direction and even
biden said during the campaign trail he
said i wish for community college to be
something that is free like the idea
that you have to pay for community
college and again we talked about our
show is like you know states have
certain rules in place in terms of uh of
you know
if if those costs are covered right
that's on a state level but on a federal
level is something inherently different
right something that republicans won't
want because they don't want people you
know they don't want educated people
they don't want people to get the
ability to use their degree to advance
their career and get a livable wage
right this is something that republicans
don't want one is the very opposite
comparison of what joe biden is
advocating for and trying to push for
and even said
i didn't get everything that i wanted
right i believe in education for three
and four-year-olds and i believe in
continuing education i believe that you
should have the ability
to go to where you want to go and not
have to pay out of the ass
for these costs right and and not have
to because the other thing too is we
talked about with brett earlier on the
show is like the actual the the fact of
getting a loan of 50 000 and by the end
of that loan repayment period 20 30
years whatever it might be you're paying
150 000 in total like principal on
interest or interest on principal like
that idea is insane that you're like now
you have to say
take this loan for 50k but by the end of
it what we don't tell you
is that if you pay the interest on all
these things for the longest amount of
time you're actually paying 2x or 3x or
whatever it might be based on what you
originally borrowed to get that
education for
so like that is broken and i and i just
want to point out the system the higher
education system and how we pay for it
right it is broken it is inherently
broken it does need to be fixed but
these small changes are going to help
people along the way right so step in
that right direction like we said
earlier and i think i think as we
reflect here because thank you for
joining us for the special coverage here
on the midas touch network and sticking
around on our show we proved that we can
do three and a half hours now our
audience is gonna be like hey hey you've
done three and a half hours because you
know we do two hours every single week
day monday through friday noon eastern
11 central nine pacific on youtube
twitter and twitch and simulcasting from
the midas touch facebook page so don't
forget to go over and follow our channel
over on youtube the tony michaels
podcast but also follow the midas touch
network here for all your special
reports that we bring to you okay we're
gonna have these hearings coming up uh
you know what hearings i'm talking about
the january 6 select hearings and we'll
be airing live here on the midas dutch
network we will be covering those
hearings as they announce them all right
so don't go anywhere make sure you stay
tuned set the set the bell notification
because we have all kinds of breaking
news stories coming to you from the
midas touch network and all the
personalities and characters we have
over here we got ben mizella's jordy
mizellis when he gets better we got
texas paul coach d we got tennessee
brando we got michael cohen the list
goes on and on and on over here and i
i'm so happy to be part of this network
to deliver you guys pro-democracy speech
because i think that is the most
important thing that we can do is
deliver pro-democracy speech
to to the people and to you and give you
truth of what our democracy is and not
do this all or nothing thing
but please do us the favor please follow
the minus touch network now don't forget
to hit that bell notification and also
go over to my channel the tony michaels
podcast follow me and gabe every single
weekday
eastern
nine
uh excuse me easter eleven 11 central
nine pacific it's been three and a half
hours we've been up here for three and a
half hours
so don't don't forget to go over and
follow us there and please watch us
every single weekday if you miss it
don't worry you can download the tony
michaels podcast on apple spotify google
wherever you get your podcast and i'm
sure i'm sure midas touch will probably
put this somewhere for you guys to see
but you can always come back to the
youtube channel if you want to refer
back to it a great conversation thanks
for sticking around gabe and thank you
brett my zealous i know you probably
he's probably out there somewhere
listening thank you for joining us and
giving us commentary on the front end
and we know at our show at our show we
have a great uh outro and because this
is still part of our show sort of i
think we should be
don't you think we should use our outro
because to all the audience out there on
a minus touch network we surf the tweety
tweets and trendy trends every single
weekday in the [ __ ] list roundup so
don't miss our show don't miss the [ __ ]
list roundup when we surf the tweety
tweets and trendy trends to hold these
fascists accountable but more than that
make sure you're getting that
pro-democracy speech that is so missed
in the media today
until tomorrow when you join us because
i know you will noon eastern 11th
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch and simulcasting from the midas
touch facebook page until then
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speech